[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i am so
supremely excited about my guest today i
have been hoping to have him on for a
very long time indeed his name is boyd
vardy you can find him on twitter at
boyd vardy
b-o-y-d-v-a-r-t-y he is the author of
two books the line tracker's guide to
life and his memoir cathedral of the
wild he's been featured in the new york
times nbc and other media and has taught
his philosophy of tracking your life to
individuals and companies around the
world i happen to know quite a few of
those individuals in fact boyd is a
wildlife and literacy activist who has
spent the last 10 years refining the art
of using wilderness as a place
for deep introspection and personal
transformation he grew up in south
africa on londolozi game reserve a
former hunting ground that was
transformed into a nature preserve by
boyd's father and uncle both visionaries
of the restoration movement
under his family stewardship the reserve
became renowned not only as a sanctuary
for animals but as a place where once
ravaged land was able to flourish again
and where the human spirit could be
restored when nelson mandela was
released after 27 years of imprisonment
he came to londolosi game reserve to
recover boyd has a degree in psychology
from the university of south africa he
is ted speaker and the host of the track
your life podcast as well you can find
him online at
boydvardy.com
b-o-y-d-v-a-r-t-y dot com on twitter
boydvarty instagram at boyd underscore
vardy boyd welcome to the show my friend
tim thanks for having me man great to be
with you
it is great to see you
and
i'm sad we're not doing this in person
but i'm also happy that you can share a
bit about your surroundings so where is
this conversation finding you right now
okay so i'm on the londolozi game
reserve in the wild eastern part of
south africa
i'm sitting in my thatched cottage
and
i'm looking out the window the river
runs below me
and currently there is a herd of
elephants that are moving down from the
far northern bank of the river to come
and feed on the delicious
spongy
palm trees in the river
so that should give you a little bit of
a sense they're two huge ebony trees
that kind of frame the house
and
a couple of weeks ago a leopard hoisted
its kill
into the tree next to the kind of
veranda of the house so that should sort
of set the scene for people a little bit
you know i had a dead bird on my porch
two days ago and i see a squirrel out to
my right so i feel like we're kind of on
equal footing there
now couple things one i want to tell you
that i don't think i've told you
actually boyd and i'm gonna pack it up
front because
i think that i am ashamed of not telling
you earlier so here you can see it and
for those who are watching video on
youtube you can see it i've got a copy
of your book here
which
you're kind enough to inscribe for me
it's the lion tracker's guide to life
i've had this for a while now
full of highlights i read it again
yesterday
and
this is one of only a handful of books
that has a dedicated shelf in my guest
bedroom
at home so in other words when people
come and visit i have a few shelves so
you have
the gift
which is of hafez poems translated by
daniel ledinsky then you have
how to change your mind by michael
pollan then you have uh awareness by
anthony develop and then you have the
line tracker's guide to life by boyd
vardy so you have you have an entire
shelf
that
people are encouraged to indulge in and
take books from in my guest bedroom i
just wanted to let you know that wow i
found myself in the company of my heroes
there thank you
absolutely it is it's a it's a fantastic
book and we're gonna dig into
all sorts of
stories that are in the book of course
many stories that
i have heard and not heard in person
with you but let's start with one that i
haven't heard but i wanted to dig into
it a little bit just as part of the
genesis story
your mom could you tell us a little bit
about your mom and then i suppose also
about your dad but specifically the get
on with it attitude as i've seen you
write it my parents met when they were
15 years old
and
my grandfather had just died leaving
this property
and everyone in in the sort of family
advisors had said to my father well
first thing you've got to get rid of
that property in the wild eastern part
of south africa
you know it's bankrupt cattle and
there's nothing going on there
there's some lions there that you used
to hunt but lion hunting is dangerous
like get rid of that
and my father stood up in the meeting of
family advisors and he said
no we're going to keep it and we'll find
a way to make it pay
and very soon after that meeting he met
my mother and with three mud huts and a
broken land rover they launched himself
into starting a safari business
and this was a time in the you know the
teeth of apartheid south africa there
was no one coming to south africa
there's a rough if any if it had been an
investor pitch and someone was saying
we're going to start a game reserve and
you know here's what we want you to
invest in no one would have invested
but together
out of the love that they had for each
other and the passion that they had for
the land
they created this amazing place
it was the love they had for each other
the passion for the land and a real big
dose of
we can keep going because this is all we
have
and so there was this incredible
attitude in both of them to just push
forward pioneer keep going raise your
kids with snakes and no electricity
people from all over the world to come
stay in a couple of mud huts give them
an incredible time
flow this amazing energy into them take
them out into the wild for encounters
and so it was that type of um get on
with that chutzpah attitude that i was
raised in and that was my mother through
and through just unbreakable you know
rub some arnica oil on it was the was
the best we got if you got an injury and
you know only call a doctor if you're
bleeding profusely or you're gonna die
all right so i have some follow-ups
first of all
everyone's saying the first thing you
have to do is get rid of that land
dad says nope we're going to keep the
land
there's got to be some thought process
behind that because
of course there are tremendous
consequences to that decision in terms
of
life trajectory why the decision why was
that decision made how was that made
i think it's a really good question i
mean there's there's a few parts to it
the one is that my great-grandfather had
bought the land in 1926
after drinking too much gin
and he heard about these bankrupt cattle
farms
that were available for sale adjacent to
the kruger national park and he was a
lion hunter and he was an adventurer and
he said well we're gonna buy
and so
he first came down here in the june of
1926
and he set up the camp you know just
sort of rugged canvas under the trees
and they would hunt lions that's how my
grandfather then grew up and then that's
how my father and uncle grew up coming
down in the winter months waking up at
dawn listening for lions to roar and
then going out to hunt lions and i
should say with lion hunting there's
only two outcomes either a lion dies or
a person dies so that gives you a little
bit of a sense for the mentality of it
but through those early days of hunting
already a deep passion had started to
take root in my father for the land and
and in my uncle they they felt connected
to it it was a place of adventure it was
it was
already a place that was infused in
meaning so when their father died and
they were teenagers and the family
advisers said okay well get rid of it i
think it's a bit of a combination of the
brilliance
the arrogance and the stupidity of youth
that just allow them to stand up and say
well we're going to keep it and we'll
make it work
i don't think that there was forethought
in the decision they just knew they were
grieving they had lost their father
it was their father's sacred place he
loved to go there and they knew that if
they
somewhere inside of that grieving
process they knew that if they let go of
the land they would lose the memory of
their father in some way and so they
held on to it and they decided well
we'll go make it work
there's so many different branches of
this tree that i can go down it's i'm
having trouble with the paradox of
choice
here
let me try to prompt
a story that will maybe speak to the
get on with it make it work
attitude of both of your parents
could you please tell the story and i'm
gonna i'm gonna give you a fragment here
so a little gingerbread crumb and see if
you remember what i'm referring to
plane ride
bird
does this mean
okay
i think you're referring to the white
knuckle charter company
yeah yeah that's the one
so basically what happened is my parents
they launched the safari business
and
it slowly started to become successful
but they started to run into a problem
as my sister and i were getting older
because school started to become an
issue so there was obviously no no way
to take us to school living out here
so they decided that what they would do
is they would learn to fly
and then they would ferry us in to the
nearest town and we would be we would
sort of attend early preschool over
whatever it's called like
monday through wednesday and then
wednesday we would fly back
to the reserve and we would be here
through the weekend and we were
basically getting three days of
schooling that seemed like enough to
them at the time
so they took up flying
and my memories of it are that when we
when they would pick us up on a
wednesday afternoon
to be honest they weren't great pilots
so they were they were in a bit of a
state you know the first 50 hours of
being a pilot there's a lot of stress
about getting it in the air and then
safely getting it back on the ground so
they would we would arrive and they
would say to us we're in flying mode
right now and flying mode meant we could
not ask any questions we had to shut up
kids you kids shut up we're in flying
mode
and then they had this other sort of
drill that they worked out with each
other which was called pilot in command
and
you know when they were up front there
in the cockpit the one would say i am
now pilot in command and if you hand it
over control you would say handing over
control and the other would say i am now
piloting command pilot in command
handing over to pilot in command i am
now pilot in command and they had this
whole drill right
the first crash that we were involved in
we came into land and we had a plane it
was a little cessna that had a quirk and
let me tell you when it comes to
aviation you don't want planes with
quirks you can have a quirky like pickup
track but you cannot have a quirky
aircraft the quirk was that when you
pulled the power
not all power cut off it kept a little
bleed of power on so my mother was
flying the plane she came into land on
the little 800 meter you know dirt strip
she cut the power the plane sort of
landed but it just kept on a little too
much power and we kept going and she
started to say to my father and my
sister and i are watching from the back
in flying mode uh i can't get the power
off i can't get the power off i can't
get the speed off and he says he's
saying to her you are pilot in command
you are pilot in command and she's going
i know but i can't get the speed off and
eventually she kicks the rudder and the
plane veers off the runway and we hit a
marilla tree and we stop
that was our that's our first crash
and it's one of those it's one of those
ones tim that if you bring it up today
like at dinner he will say we'll say
well you know i couldn't get the speed
off and he'll say my father will say
well you're a pilot in command and
immediately a fight will develop at
dinner i know i was patted in command
but before we hit the tree do you think
you could have pulled the power you
could've so like it's a little tension
around it anyway
the worst one was
we were flying a short hop and by this
stage
my parents had launched you know a
bigger safari company
and they had decided that when they flew
they should actually have a commercial
pilot with them and so the setup was
it's a commercial pilot in the left-hand
seat it's my father in the right-hand
seat and then there's
club seating four seats in the back so
but you sit facing each other like you
would on a train you know like looking
at each other
so we're flying along and i see my
mother and her friend are sitting
opposite me
and they're looking towards the cockpit
i'm looking back at them and suddenly we
just hear this outrageous like sound
and wind fills the cockpit and it's just
this incredible rushing sound
amazing sound
looking at my mother and her friend next
to her
it looks like pulp fiction there is just
blood and guts all over them it looks
like someone took a bird put it in a
blender and made like a bird smoothie
and then threw it over them they've got
a wing on their head they've got a foot
on their shoulder they are covered in
blood and guts and so i turn and i look
back at the cockpit the front window of
the plane is gone
the pilot is conked out he's passed out
in his seat and my father is like
orientating himself in the madness
and
right at that moment as he sort of as my
father got his bearings i saw him grab
the controls and then he looked back at
me and said
i am pilot in command
and
and so now
now we we realize we've got a situation
what had happened is we had hit
a stalk direct bird strike and the bird
had come in the window
and in fact
the beak of the bird had gone into had
hit the pilot the bird had hit the pilot
the beak had gone into the skin
um between the pilot's skull and the
skin so he had a beak sticking out of
his face and a bit of stalk neck
sticking out of his face and he's
totally passed out meantime my father
has taken control of the plane the woman
on the back seat screaming next to my
mom is going we're all gonna die we're
all gonna die and that's when my mother
gave her the patented mother slap
slapped her twice and said we are not
gonna die
and then out of nowhere my mother
reaches into her sort of handbag and
pulls out a flight call sheet and she
starts screaming standard emergency
practices to my father
call sos bass request emergency landing
and he's ticking off things
now at this point the pilot starts to
wake up
and he wakes up and he's slowly gaining
his bearings
and
as he looks around he has this strange
kind of
dot in his vision and as he's looking
around the dot follows him
and he eventually puts his hand up and
what it is it's the stalk's neck
sticking out of his face that everywhere
he looks it's in his line of sight
because it's connected to his face
and it was at that moment that he
grabbed the neck and the beak of the
stalk and he pulled it out of his face
and looked at it and then passed out
again
and i don't know if you've ever seen a
head wound but head wounds bleed nicely
and so he's bleeding quite intensely
it's pandemonium back it there but my
folks have got the controls they call
the airport my father starts the descent
and eventually the pilot wakes up and he
comes too and he's actually he's all
right and he takes over control of the
plane again and we do an emergency
landing
and the funny thing about it was we were
flying from the reserve to go and catch
a commercial flight so we landed at a
commercial airport and we got out
covered in stork stalk wing and stork
foot and stork guts and we walked into
the terminal building and i said to my
mother well what do we do now she said
just board the flight and look forward
so we got onto the plane looking like we
had been in the texas chainsaw massacre
and just sat down next to regular folks
traveling
covered in guts and blood and just sat
there and looked forward and and flew to
our next destination like nothing had
happened
but it was a you know we grew up in a
real wild way we grew up in a pioneering
way and my parents were
irrepressible i think is the word
but you kind of have to be to run a
safari business where things
you know running a safari business
you're out in nature and things are
happening
and and unexpected things are happening
almost continuously so that was kind of
a
my wild youth in some ways you know was
very
very orientated towards that kind of
south african wildness and and also i
think that we were we've changed a lot
over the years but
and we've been in our own healing
journeys and our own healing journeys
have changed us as a family for sure
but for many years there we were just
kind of packing on uh
you know i guess we were frozen by some
trauma ourselves and we were just living
as wildly through it as we could
hmm
well i remember the first time for the
hell of an elder story man
i totally forgot about the boarding the
the next connecting
awkward blood covered moments yeah it'd
be hard to get past tsa covered and
covered in viscera
uh good lord so
let's talk about
another element i believe of your
childhood you could tell me when this
first enters the picture we're gonna
bounce all over the place
but
and please correct my pronunciation
when did the
schengen trackers say schengen how do
you pronounce that properly
there we go shanghai trackers enter the
picture in your life
and who are they and you pray you could
you could answer that in either order
firstly let me say something about the
shangan people the shangan people are
the most wonderful people that i've had
time to spend time with in africa they
were a splinter tribe of the zulu people
and basically they they went on a
warring party and they found themselves
in southern mozambique and they decided
that they were actually more peaceful
people they didn't want to be involved
in the zulu armies war-like ways and
they broke away and they really
you know
pastoral people amazing storytellers
incredible trackers because they love to
observe things and tell stories
and so from the time my father and uncle
were very young and from the time that i
was very young
i was i was lucky to spend time with
some of the best shanghaine trackers in
the world men who had grown up hunting
and gathering in the region
and the transition that we went through
as a family is
we grew up tracking to hunt and then we
once we had a kind our kind of
enlightenment experience and we decided
we must partner with the land and we
must think of the animals as our kin we
continued tracking but it was to find
animals for photographic safaris
and so from the time that i was
extremely young i was apprenticed to
these master shangan trackers
and i spent hundreds of hours
learning the art form of following an
animal across wild terrain and learning
how to be attuned to the language of the
wilderness and i was listening to your
interview with noah feldman and he was
talking about how language attunes you
in a different way to a culture
and if you can think of tracking
tracking is essentially the language of
the wilderness you're learning the signs
the sounds and
as your knowledge as a tracker deepens
it's like you're being let into another
level and the shanghaine people were
deeply attuned to this and they taught
me that from a young age and really the
success of londolozi to create a bit of
context for how the safari business came
together
my father was 15 my uncle was 17 my
mother was about 15 too and they were
going to launch the safari business
most of the land at that time because
the cattle had overgrazed the land it
was kind of an eye-high scrub
and
all of the animals were here
but you didn't really see them and in
fact they had been hunted so any animals
you saw were trying to get away from you
and really my my parents struggled to
get the safari business going
and then they had a defining moment and
that was the arrival
of a kind of maverick ecologist by the
name of ken tinley
and ken had ken was an amazing guy he
was a high school dropout
who got admitted to a biological
sciences degree
because he drew a picture of a moth
with such intricate detail that the dean
of the faculty put him in
and
and he studied his biological sciences
degree and then he went to live alone in
mozambique and write a dissertation
and during this time living alone ken
had this incredible encounter with
wilderness and he felt deeply attuned to
it and the way he described it he said
it felt like he could feel the rivers
moving through his veins and he became
aware of how the moisture traveled
through the terrain and how that
informed the flora and how that then
informed the the fauna and he was just
deeply in tune
and he showed up next to the campfire
one day where these young upstarts were
trying to get the safari business going
and he said to them if you want this
place to work you must partner with the
land you must think of the animals as
your kin
and you must make sure that the local
shangan people are invited to
participate in this restoration
and so they said to him
partner with the land what do you mean
and he said come i'll show you
and he walked them out onto the
scrub-encroached land
and he said to them when the cattle
overgraze the land the moisture falls
but instead of penetrating the soil it
runs off in these deep erosive furrows
so what you do is you clear away the
scrub and you take that scrub scrub and
you pack it into the furrows and it's
kind of like putting the plug back in
the bath and with that you start to
charge the grassland with moisture and
he started to show them how to restore
the micro catchments on the property
and
i really grew up
one of the first imprints of my psyche
was watching the land being restored i
would go to a place where there was eye
high scrub and then i would see the
destitution as you cut it out and then
you would go back there a year later and
there would be a herd of water back on
it and a herd of zebra and then a rhino
walking through it in the late evening
and so
my first impulses i believe as a healer
came out of watching the way that life
knows how to bring itself forth
and then one day after a day spent
working on the land my father and my
uncle were driving home
and in the late afternoon light a female
leopard stepped out onto the road in
front of them
and up until that point any leopard you
saw was ears back running to get away
from you they'd been hunted
but this leopard stopped
and she turned and she looked at them
and for a moment she allowed herself to
be seen
and then she growled and they saw that
she had this one broken canine and then
she slipped away from there
and they drove home in silence and they
stopped the vehicle
and my uncle who was a rugged aggressive
wild type guy
they sat there for a moment in silence
and then he looked at my father and he
said
whatever just happened that's my future
and i've been deeply interested in that
my whole life you know to your point
like what made them say we're gonna try
and take on the creation of the safari
business
what made my great grandfather after too
many jinns say i'm gonna buy what made
my uncle say in that moment that's my
future how do we know when we know
so what my uncle did is he teamed up
with a shanghaine tracker one of the
best trackers in the area a man by the
name of almonim shlongo
and almond is actually rhenius in the
books brothers incredible hunter groudon
incredibly in tuned
and maybe just for a second before we
get to elmo if you could just as context
because people hear tracking good
trackers they might not realize
just how far back a lineage of
tracker to tracker to tracker
tradition might extend are we talking
hundreds of years thousands of years
tens of thousands of years i mean how
far back does it go right this this type
of skill development and
generational passing down i mean this
goes back to our this goes back to our
mast early origins
some people say
that tracking is in some ways the
beginning of science because it's the
beginning of deduction
it's the beginning the first time that
someone looked at a abstract imprint and
started to apply meaning to it
and it's an art form that has been alive
it lives inside of people because it has
been passed on through generations you
know a tracker will teach another
tracker the way and so i think of it as
this art form that you can't hang on the
wall or it like literally has to be
alive in a person to survive yeah so it
didn't mean to interrupt i just wanted
to kind of set the stage right because
people think like oh my
my grandfather did this my dad did this
i now do this therefore we have this
this extensive lineage which is true on
some scale but
when you refer to one of these
master trackers
it's it's quite a different level of
kind of
longevity in terms of the the bloodline
and the development of that skill
ancient back to the back to the origins
of humanity
yeah and when you are tracking you are
connected
to that entire lineage you know which
which is amazing feeling somewhat what
i'm doing right now
thousands of years ago someone did this
very same practice
yeah
and almond was just brilliant in the
bush and so what my uncle and him did is
for the next 12 years they woke up every
morning and they went out and they
tracked that leopard
and just in
insane drive and dedication and
sometimes they would go
two weeks without seeing her and they
would be putting together the clues
they'd be following the tracks
and then it started to be that they
would find her and she would allow
herself to be viewed from 2 300 yards in
a vehicle
and then slowly over time that space
that distance started to close
and eventually after a few years of this
it got to the point where they could
actually drive one of these old land
rovers in next to her
and she had developed a relationship of
trust with them it was a totally wild
leopard and she knew that these men
meant her no harm
we called that leopard the mother
leopard because she went on to have
eight litters of cubs and all of those
cubs grew up modeling their mother's
trust
and so she was the mother for two
reasons one because she was the mother
of all these cubs and second because
really she was the mother of
the birth of the safari business because
word got out that there was a place in
the middle of south africa
where no one wanted to go where you
could go and see a wild leopard
and that allure is still alive inside of
people today but it would have been
absolutely impossible without the skills
and the brilliance of the shangan
trackers to be able to go out into a
vast wilderness
and attune yourself to the faint tracks
of where this animal had walked to
listen for alarm calls to listen to bird
language and to start to get to know her
movement patterns her territories where
she liked to den all of that made it
possible and it wouldn't have been
possible without great trackers and so
that really the legacy of londolozi is a
legacy of relationships between trackers
and wild animals you mentioned a name
that comes up a lot in the line
tracker's guide to life
who's of course a fascinating character
in the book and i'm sure in in in real
life even more so fascinating
renis is that how you say this name
properly
rhenius matanjana jampacha zimzongo is
his official name that's exactly what i
was going to say
i'll stick with the radios for short now
i want to prompt
maybe as a way of
of describing renis and introducing him
uh question that came or cue that came
from
one of our mutual friends josh waitzkin
and he said
ask boyd about renis not returning to
camp a few weeks ago when tracking i
think a male lion when all the clients
wanted to come back
could you tell this story are you open
to that yeah renis is firstly one of the
best trackers in the world i would say
that he's he's top five
he's deeply attuned and what and my
definition of mastery is someone who can
be themself in any situation
and really what makes renier special is
that he's able to totally be himself
wherever he goes
and
i'm sure you've seen this in other
disciplines he's one of those rare
masters who's able to
translate
the intangibles of what he knows how to
do you learn by being around him you
learn by absorbing his presence watching
how he moves but he's also quite good at
teaching
which makes him really exceptional
because a lot of trackers will you'll
say to them why did you know to go down
there why did you know to check that
riverbed and they just sort of say i
just knew
renis is able to dissect it a little bit
for you but
this to me is the level of his mastery
we ran
a retreat a tracking retreat we had some
folks from all over the world who had
come on one of our tracking retreats and
it was day four and we had had an
exceptional time we had found and
followed animals
the night before we had slept out in the
bush
and so the next morning we woke up
we found tracks of a single male lion
and we began to follow and after two or
three hours i could see that the guests
who were on the retreat were tiring they
were running out of gas they'd been
keeping watch all night
can you explain what you mean by that
keeping watch all night afraid that
lions are going to eat them all night
yeah on the retreat one of the nights we
had slept on the ground in the open no
vehicle no tents and each person had
been asked
to keep watch it's this deeply
archetypal experience to be awake around
the fire
it definitely changes what the fire
means to you is from this ancient
primordial sense of like fire safety
and each person keeps watch through the
night and it's beautiful you're alone
owls calling stars above you and this
alertness alive inside of you as you
keep watch for your friends
what are you keeping watch i guess i
guess but just sorry not to bog the
story down but just for a second like if
john from kpmg in chicago who's never
camped before comes to track and retreat
i would be kind of nervous
trusting john to keep me alive while i
slept so i probably wouldn't sleep i'm
just wondering what one does when
they're keeping watch
no
kpmg it just came to mind no
john from kp g taking contact well the
thing is is that
the minute you get out there and night
starts to fall and some lions roar
nearby and an elephant walks past your
camp and comes to investigate
what's pretty amazing tim is that no one
misses the gravity of the situation
yeah i bet there's something about night
falling like i watch people switch on
and i explain to them that if you
if you fall asleep during your watch or
you don't do this properly someone can
get badly injured
and so people take it very seriously and
your job on watch is to be an aware
presence
and
you get armed with a really good torch
you listen
you tune in flashlight for you yeah
that's nice
and if any animal comes you have to be
aware of its presence and there's an
amazing thing if you're aware of an
animal's presence it's aware that you're
aware of it and that's the critical
safety piece
and we've never in all the years we've
been doing it and we've slept out with
many many people we've never had anyone
let us down because people feel the the
gravity of it and something does wake up
inside of them
so anyway back to the story we yeah
suffice to say they didn't sleep very
well they didn't sleep very well so like
10 o'clock the next morning they were
flagging and we decided because we had
such a good time and we've been so lucky
with the tracking already we were going
to call it there we're going to say guys
we're going to leave this track and
we're going to head back to the camp
now irenaeus has been 30 years
into guiding people you know even more
35 years into guiding people and then
another section working as a trainer
he says
you guys go back to camp i can't leave
this track
and i'm fascinated by that moment
because there are so many hundreds of
guides so many hundreds of people who
say you know what our guests are happy
eggs benedict back at the camp
but his mastery is that he can't leave
it there is
there is something laid down in front of
him that he's curious about he's
interested and he has to know
something in the tracker has to
discover has to find out
and
the scope of the the years of his
practice and the fact that he makes that
decision to stay out there hot tired
without water he needs to know that is
his art form he needs to be in it
there's something very special about
that to me
which animals
are hardest to track
at londoloza you mentioned
a leopard right so a leopard in my mind
i think of solitary animal
as i understand it
sleeps in trees at least part of the
time as i understand it again i have no
understanding of leopards
uh so i would think of them as difficult
to track
for a number of different reasons but
which which animals
that you track are easiest and which are
hardest
oh well i think you've nailed it they're
leopard by some margin is the most
difficult
one
it walks its solitary and it walks
incredibly lightly
and it its nature is solitary and
secretive it likes to operate in thick
terrain
anytime you're seeing a leopard the
leopard is allowing you to see it which
to me has this beautiful mystery that it
cloaks it in
so leopard by quite some margin would be
the most difficult and
and we've had trackers here who become
real specialists at following leopards
we used to have a tracker by the name of
richard uh soeller
and zoella was
he was meticulous in his dress and he
was gruff
and he was hard to get along with he was
rude to most people
he had that kind of that arrogance born
of being brilliant he deserved all the
arrogance he had because he was so good
and he used to do this thing where if
all the trackers been out in the morning
and they'd been following a leopard
they would come back to camp they'd been
unsuccessful they had a last track but
they had lost it he would go back there
and it used to be my favorite thing he
would go back at 12 o'clock in the
afternoon he would refuse to go with
anyone else he wanted to go alone and he
would slowly start to
work that track
and then eventually at like six o'clock
in the evening you'd get a radio call
and it would be richard and he would say
i've located this leopard he would tell
you where it was and then his final
refrain was
richard zoella is number one
and he did it he did it so consistently
and
richard zoella was number one
that's amazing that is amazing technical
question 12 noon so i would think that
high noon would actually be a hard time
to track because
it wouldn't
cast shadows as well but is the reason
for doing that that the animals are
bedded down due to the heat so that
you're
able to track while they're in one place
why would he go out at 12 noon
one is he's showing people how good he
is because you're right the the direct
light creates a flat
aspect on the ground the light is flat
and so you're right there's no shadow
there's no contrast when the light is
lower it bounces off where the animal
has stepped in a it changes the texture
on the earth he's going at midday
because no one else wants to go out in
the heat he's showing i go out in the
heat he's going at midday because the
light is flat and he's saying i go out
when the light is flat
he's going at midday because he knows
that that leopard is going to be lying
up somewhere and so if he can get a
track he can close the distance on it
while it's not moving
and all of those are saying
soiler is number one
it's so great
i love that so let me ask because people
will no doubt be wondering
what type of protection does one have
when say renius goes out to track with
clientele do you have a the equivalent
of a swat team with you with
rifles at the ready in case any danger
presents itself i think i know the
answer to this but just because i know
people may have a question mark in their
minds
what type of protection do you guys
carry so when we are tracking with
clients
we will carry rifles and and always if
we're running specifically tracking
retreats we will be a two rifle
operation
but really
but really the protection is way
upstream of that
in all of my years in the bush i've
never had to use the rifle
the art form of tracking is what makes
you safe
and when you're with someone like renius
the safety profile
just becomes exceptionally safe because
he's so attuned
and so it's a capacity to read the
terrain to make good decisions
to be attuned to the freshness of the
track where those animals will be how we
should approach different terrain
attuned to the birds bird language
and then
whereinius
is even more exceptional is that you
know the way that an animal communicates
with you is through a state of presence
it if it is unhappy with you it conveys
energy through the way its body shapes
and
really amazing trackers are able to
read that body language and almost speak
back to it in the way they move their
body
and you can convey a very profound
unspoken language
and i think of it as a language of
energy or a language of presence and
that is really what makes you safe as
that animal if you see that animal how
you convey your intentions to it your
mood
what you do if it does become aggressive
with you how you meet that
and shape the sort of the unspoken
conversation between you
i want to bring up one of the lines
from
the line tracker's guide to life that
it certainly pops to mind quickly when i
think about this book i'm sure it's a
line that a lot of people bring up i
know it's a line that josh has brought
up
and i'd love to just hear you
explain
why this is in the book and why it
matters
quote i don't know where we're going but
i know exactly how to get there
i love that don't you
i love it absolutely it's uh
it really if you take a moment to pause
and contemplate it the the implications
are pretty profound so i'd love to just
hear you
riff on this and why
and how this ended up in the book
well there were two things that rhaenyas
used to say regularly the one is
his
we will get we will get it
and it was almost like this kind of
incredible self-talk that he would have
when the track was cold or the track was
you know we weren't making progress i
would look at him and he would say ah
we're gonna get this
and then
often he would say to
i don't know where i'm going but i know
exactly how to get there and what he's
saying he's talking to the dynamic of
tracking which is
it's an interesting energetic dynamic he
is profoundly committed
to finding that animal but he hasn't
allowed that commitment to become a
burden of some kind he is working moment
to moment on the signs that he's getting
and you can think in a vast wilderness
as trackers we also talk about the first
track in a vast wilderness 360 degrees
of wild terrain
all he needs is the next first track and
then the next first track and then the
next first track and the next first
track
and he's able to dial down the infinite
possibilities of where that animal could
have gone to a moment of knowing and a
moment of presence and then another
moment of knowing and another moment of
presence and all he needs is that next
sign and so he doesn't know where it's
going but he knows how to get there the
next moment of presence the next thing i
know to do
and it might be a good segue there to
just telling you a little bit about how
the tracking process changed for me over
the years let's do it
davin so i had these encounters tim
whereby
i had a childhood following animals and
learning this art form and really the
dynamics and the psyche of the tracker
how a tracker approached the process of
finding an animal in the middle of
nowhere
and then watching how consistently good
trackers delivered an outcome they found
the animal they were looking for and so
that and at that time as a young child i
thought i was learning that skill
and then
through my early 20s i had a series of
pretty traumatic encounters
and the result of that was that by the
time i was about 23 or 24 years old i
had found myself
frozen by trauma i felt i was depressed
i was uncertain how to move forward and
in the way that trauma limits options i
felt my myself extremely limited i did
not have access to
you know a lot of emotionality i did not
have access to different choices i was
stuck
and at that time i was very lucky to
meet a woman who who came on safari and
she was my first she became my first
mentor and the reason i guided her was
because alex my friend who also features
in the book
he had guided her a year before and he
said to me she's a martial artist
and i was very interested in martial
arts as i know you are and so i went
into the guide room and in the guide
room there was this board where
every guide got their name put next to
the clients who were coming in and i
rubbed off someone else's name and i put
my name next to her to guide her and
that moment absolutely changed my life
her name was dr martha beck
and she arrived on the safari and we
went out the first two days
and she said something
on the second day that i felt something
in me like
really moved
we were driving along and i was telling
her about the restoration of the land
and she said i really understand this
and i believe the restoration of the
planet will come out of a transformation
in human consciousness
and the minute she said it you know
whatever my grandfather knew or my
father knew or my uncle knew when he saw
that lay but i felt that thing move
inside of me that kind of
that idea struck me very deeply
and then on about the fourth day
i i'd driven back to the camp and you
know i'm in my safari gear i got my
rifle you know i'm the guide i'm rugged
guy i'm out there tracking lines
and she turned and she looked at me and
she said
i'm ready to talk to you
and i was sort of taken aback i said
well what do you mean
she said i can see what you're carrying
and i can see how stuck you are and i
want you to know that i can help you and
i'm here
and i don't know if you've ever had one
of those instances where someone sees
you when you're in your when you're in
one of those places
but i felt myself becoming really
uncertain and then i felt tears starting
to come to my eyes and then there was
this moment where the you know this
woman is hugging the safari guide and
just consoling me
and she was an incredible healer and she
was
exceptionally adept at transformational
processes
and so she started to teach me
how to move through
the trauma and the suffering that i was
stuck in
and as that happened
my relationship to tracking started to
change and i started to see this art
form in a different way and i realized
that i was looking for something
and all of the skills and the mentality
of the tracker was highly adept to being
in a transformational process
you know the first thing that you will
have to do if you want to go track a
lion in the wild
is you will have to become super
uncomfortable with unknowns
you'll have to give up all the ways you
try to know what to do and say i don't
know how to do this
um
all trackers operate using unknowns to
almost bring them to life you know
you will need to develop your track
awareness track awareness is teaching
yourself to be attuned to a very
specific set of signs metrics but
self-generated you know like when i was
a kid renis would take me out to a game
path and he would say
walk down that game path and tell me
what you see
and i would come back and i would say to
him i saw a herd of impala walk there
and he would say hey i'm fine
young boy go look again
and as i was walking away he would say
puza matipel say put your head down like
like the way an animal drinks
put your head right down against the
trail and look like you're drinking
water like an animal
and i would come back and i would say i
can see where they heard of impala
walked but they actually walked over the
tracks of a leopard and i can see where
a mouse ran across the path and then an
owl swooped down and its wing touched
the ground
and each time i walked down that path
under his guidance there was more
information
and that idea became very important to
me the idea that there is information in
your life if you are looking for
transformation but you have to teach
yourself to attune to it
and so you know what do you need to
attune to in transformational processes
things that make you feel expensive
things that make you feel alive letting
go of your rational idea of what you
should do and noticing what you move
towards noticing what you're curious
about noticing the people who energize
you the activities that make you feel
more alive
so i started to see through the eyes of
the tracker the first track
you know the first track being the next
thing you know to do letting go of
you know where that animal might be or
letting go of where you think you should
be and just doing the next thing you
know to do and the next thing you know
to do
if you watch great trackers they drop
into what i call the following state
and it's so beautiful if you watch alex
and renis in the following state
the following straight could be defined
almost as constant creative response to
what is occurring if the track cuts left
alex will click and he'll say i'm on the
track if it cuts right rhenius will be
on it they're getting a sense of the
mood of the animal
they're using their own body to attune
to the way the animal is moving and in
that way like almost feel the animal as
it's walking out ahead of them at the
same time they are vectoring and they
are getting a sense of their bearings
using waypoints of marula trees up ahead
and they're having when you watch them
they're almost having fun in it they're
playing they're playing on that track
and so you will need to develop the
following state in your own
transformational process how can you
play how can you be creative with
not knowing what you're trying to create
or this place you're trying to get to
but being open and willing and aware and
attuned
you will almost certainly lose the track
and i i'm sort of saying this to see how
the tracker came to me in a different
way as i got into my own journey of
healing
you will lose the track you'll be in the
middle of it thinking i'm deep in the
following state i'm right on track and
then suddenly it'll be gone
and you will need to build community
around you of other great trackers
people who are willing to move with you
follow with you
and the core of it is really that there
is something inside of you that knows
there is a part of you you might call it
your wild self you might call it the
track of your life or as native people
call it your medicine way a part of you
that
beyond rational thought reacts when you
become more in tune with yourself
and shifting away the layers of
socialization all the things you should
do all the things you have to do to
start to be able to follow the trail of
that place inside of you became
really what the core of my own journey
to healing was
and i lived like that to this day as a
tracker
trying to be present resting into the
unknown attuning and trying to fall into
the following state with what energizes
me makes me curious and pulls me forward
thank you for that it it strikes me also
that
a lot of
people who would
try to help another start
almost as a
hammer looking for nails right they
they don't
listen enough first and it just strikes
me that
what martha did was
very much
initially
demonstrated by
her powers of observation awareness and
attunement right and those are sort of
like the core fundamental
characteristics
that you need to develop or resurrect
before you can really prescribe anything
at all right and
the question i want to ask is actually
related to the traumatic events if
you're open to it
i'd
would you be willing to share what
happened or some of the examples of what
happened in your 20s yeah just one
comment on martha when i
once we started to get onto that level
with each other when i watched her
and i looked at her what i saw was a
superb tracker
she understood how
trauma patterns us
and she was
incredibly adept at first tracking the
pattern and then starting to support you
in creating a different outcome for
yourself or providing tools and options
for different ways of doing it and as i
watched her work with myself and with
many other people i saw a tracker who
would you know at first just really
observe and get to know what they were
working with and be present and attuned
and and that's really what most
attracted to me to her work was that i
was i saw a tracker of processes human
processes and
first and foremost and that's probably
what i was mature enough the frame that
i was
able to see through at that time as a
tracker
but yeah to segue into my own
experiences
my family i would say tim went through a
very difficult 10-year period a period
of intense suffering
and
and yet that suffering became the place
where we learned to do the work and go
inward and start to understand how
healing processes work and so
i've gotten to the place now where i've
i fondly look back on those 10 years of
initiation you know university of
suffering
but it began for me
when my grandmother died
my father who had
he had taken the londolozi model of care
of land care of wildlife care of people
and he had launched it to 30 other
operations around southern africa
which mandela had asked him to do and so
he had been this big sort of expansion
and then in a classic kind of change of
founder's trap he got fired from that
and then very soon into that south
africa was going through a very very
difficult time
and one night we were in johannesburg
and this was
post elections but it was still
it was still
you know very
the country was still really finding its
feet and there was a ton of violent
crime still happening
and
i was yeah as i said i was 18 years old
and i i woke up and my sister was
shaking me and immediately as i sat up i
had a gun pushed into my face
and
the home that we were staying in
johannesburg and that occasion had been
invaded
and i just felt
you know the adrenaline pumped through
my system and
all of my work
as in healing spaces later and i know
that you're involved in psychedelic
assisted therapy has been to try and get
a cap on the scope of
uh where my body goes when it gets a
mild trauma because i woke up into my
worst nightmare and i look to my left
and my mother's tied up
on the floor and my sister's tied up
and i know kind of
stories of how these things go the
violence uh the potential danger to
women and it was just like absolute
redline fear
and just to see the woman in my life my
family like that and
so it's just shocking and then
realizing that
you know i know i can read animals i
can't quite read people like i mean i
can't quite read them it's they don't
they're not as honest as animals you
know so i just don't know where this is
going to go and i'm sitting in this
tension
and eventually
they took me
they took me outside
and these
these guys had broken into the house and
they said to me we're going to kill you
and
so they pulled me outside and they put a
gun to my head
and they said this is they basically
said now we're going to kill you
and
you know the fear was so intense and
then i remember looking up the barrel at
the man who was holding the gun to my
head and we looked into each other's
eyes
and in that moment something happened
which
i can't say what happened you might call
it the peace of god that paths
understanding but
i think it was too big for my ego
structure to hold and it and it
collapsed
and as i looked at him all fear left me
and all concern for my own bodily safety
left me and i just felt a profound human
connection with him
and as that happened and there were
three of these guys standing around me
as as that moment happened it was kind
of this this weird
the only way i can describe it is a kind
of a weirdness came over everyone it was
as if everyone had become glimmered
and they put the guns down and everyone
just stood there confused
and i walked back inside totally un uh
and accosted in any way and i got
the car keys and i walked back out and i
gave them the car keys and i said get in
that car and leave
and they did
and it was just
immensely bizarre and
and for years i lived with trying to
work out both the terror that i felt and
the the fear that had flooded me but
also trying to integrate like whatever
had happened in that moment
um and i'm not sure that i i fully
understand it but
you know i i felt like i glimpsed
through the most terrifying situation i
i glimpsed something
and so that was that was a very very
sort of that was the first freezing
experience that i had
it was terrifying
and then on the heels of that
and i think sometimes of jung's um
jung's uh description of like
what is unconscious will be made
conscious it will manifest into your
life until you become more conscious
about what you're carrying
a couple of weeks after that
literally in the same year
myself and a friend
myself and some friends and another
tracker called soliantrongo we went down
to the river on the reserve
and it was an extremely hot day and we
left the people who we were guiding
sort of sitting under a tree and we
began to walk upstream in the river
and sully stayed on the bank
and i was actually walking in the water
and the water was knee-deep
running over sand and you could see
quite clearly
and then there was a place up ahead
where a tree had fallen over and its
branches were in the water and it was
kind of shadowy and i when i think of it
now i think like if it had been a horror
movie you know people in the audience
would have started saying don't go near
the shadowy place
um and of course as i walked past the
shadowy place i actually sat down just
on the edge of those shadows and my
perception was that the water was too
shallow for crocodiles but of course the
crocodile was in the hole
and
the first thing that you notice when a
crocodile grabs you is just the ferocity
and the pressure of the bite
i just felt it slam onto my right leg
and it tries to pull me into the deep
section of the water
i throw my arm up and i grab a branch
and it starts to shake me and i see a
slick of blood appear in the water and
then it gets washed downstream
while the crocodile is shaking me i see
sully who's on the bank he sees me and
he sees that i'm in trouble
and he immediately starts making his way
towards me
sully is also a shanghai man grew up
hunting and gathering
the croc goes to bite me a second time
and i kicked and by the grace of god my
foot went down its throat and it spat me
out
and i pulled myself up into the branches
of the tree
and i have this memory of almost being
non-local watching myself pull myself
up into the branches of the tree i got
up into the branches and i remember
looking over my shoulder and my leg from
the knee down is just absolutely mangled
torn to pieces and meat hanging off
i made a pact with myself in that moment
like never look at that again
and i made my way through the branches
and i fell onto the bank
and i knew that i was extremely
vulnerable on the bank crocodiles it's
an elite predator if it thinks it can
get you and i was on the bank against
the water it's going to grab me again
at that point sully coming from the
other bank arrives at the deep section
of the channel
he's seen me come out of the water
he's seen that my leg is mangled and he
knows that in the deep channel of water
between him and i is a crocodile
and i can tell you that man didn't slow
down not for one second he plunged into
the water he waded into almost over his
hips and he got to me on the bank and he
grabbed me put me on his shoulder and he
carried me up onto the bank he took his
shirt off he wrapped it around my leg we
were able to call the folks who were
with us and calm them down radio a plane
that was flying over and i was able to
get medivacked out and
and we were able to stop the bleeding so
that i would i survived
so you know those two experiences were
very alive in me
and maybe this is a side point and and
then i'll slow down for a while but uh
you know in the in the months after that
i sat many many times with sully
and i said to him sorry
you know why did you come in the water
and he would look at me with disdain and
he'd say um
he said my brother you're in trouble i'm
in trouble.
and at first i thought it was some kind
of like you know platitude he was
playing down his actions
but as time went on i really understood
and i came to see that in the way that
sully grew up he grew up in a much more
collective consciousness he grew up with
his tribe he grew up hunting and
gathering he grew up in nature
and he lived in a much more
interconnected way
than
than any of us lived he in fact his
whole psyche was not formed around
individuality
his psyche was formed around a wee
consciousness you and me together a
collective consciousness and to him it
was fundamental if i was in trouble he
was in trouble and so he did not see it
as any kind of heroic action he just saw
it as the most obvious natural thing to
do and and that really that moved me and
that and that taught me a lot
i'm going to come back to a number of
things
first
good lord i'm sorry both these things
happened even though it ended up being
the university of suffering
those are two excruciating
experiences to put it mildly
but just based on what you
said about
this collective
consciousness does the word ubuntu or
the concept of ubuntu tie into this
in any way
oh absolutely could you explain that for
folks
yeah ubuntu is an african philosophy
that says i am because of you
or people are not people without other
people
and what ubuntu is talking to is the
relational nature of life and
the point i want to make about it is
that it is in when you spend time
with people where the ubuntu
consciousness is activated in them where
ubuntu is alive in them
it is actually a kind of structuring in
their very psyche they experience things
in relation
they experience each other in a
relational way
and
they know that knowing yourself and
being yourself is about being connected
to people but also to the broader field
of sentient life
and
and so what what sully was activating
there was the ubuntu consciousness and
he was showing that ubuntu consciousness
comes alive in action through courageous
action in that case but very much what
he was showing me that day was
was how deeply ingrained it was in him
that the collective nature of life
another way of saying it tim is like and
this gets really interesting and as you
start to learn your own psyche
but different cultures the psyches are
structured differently and in a more
western setting
you know you might say that in a society
where the individual self is
disconnected from the greater
interconnectivity of life
the search for meaning
is reduced to a constant state of
comparison
so people will always on some level be
saying how am i doing in comparison and
so
a lot of and so many people are living
with that without even knowing that
that's how they're trying to orientate
themselves whereas if you grew up in
africa or if you grew up in nature
you grew up relationally so it's not
comparative it's more like i'm learning
about myself through my encounter with
the world
i'm going to try to maybe awkwardly tie
a number of things together here
when you and
i i think it was when we first spent
time together
i can't remember maybe it was the first
time we spoke but you were just coming
off of
living in a tree if i remember correctly
if you're open to talking about that
and uh if not we can certainly cut it
later but since we're talking about it
how many days were you in this tree
i was 40 days and 40 nights in the tree
if you read all the mystical traditions
including i think your your man hafiz on
your bookshelf but in all the mystical
traditions
there seems to be a time when the
mystics are drawn to be alone in nature
and you know jesus went for 40 days and
40 nights the buddha went to the grove
there's accounts of it all along the way
and so i wanted to go and have that
experience myself and i'm not saying i'm
a mystic but i wanted my question was
why did all of the mystics go to be in
total solitude in nature
and so with a lockdown in the world
suddenly i had six weeks where i could
go and do that you know go and sit in
that question and see what answers came
to me during that time the first was
that initially there was a tremendous
anxiety you know the first couple of
days i had a lot of thoughts around
you know i'm going to be away i'm going
to miss something i'm not attending to
and then after three days that all
dropped
and i know the aboriginal people have
this amazing saying that modern culture
is three days deep
and after three days i started i felt
myself going to a different state of
consciousness i just realized it doesn't
matter
and then i started to attune myself to
the natural world
and a few things happened the one is
that a big insight was that where your
attention goes your life goes and if
you're constantly putting your attention
on living things
there's more aliveness in your own life
that was that was one the second was
that if you spend time in nature in the
same spot over a period of time it
starts to become incredibly personal so
it's not just a bird or
or that antelope it's that bird that
roosts in that bush and flies down the
riverbed in the morning and back up the
southern bank and then it feeds for
grubs in this tree and as you start to
become more personally attuned to each
animal you start to see that there's a
pattern to that to their movement and in
fact then you start to find yourself
orientated inside of a series of
interlocking intelligences that is
really what the natural world is
and then at some point
you realize that
i'm not observing this this intelligence
that i'm watching unfold around me i'm
fundamentally a part of this and it
stops being a mental construct and you
start to feel yourself inside of that
intelligence
and
that's a very very deep experience or at
least it was for me and i'm i think that
that is why at a certain point the
mystics went to go and get quiet enough
to feel themselves inside of that
incredible field of intelligence that is
the natural world
i had just radical encounters every day
and i think that's another thing about
the natural world is
you know things happen and as things
happen each day it almost like it helps
you make meaning and in a society you
know the societies of the modern world
are almost becoming devoid of the
structures that allow us to make meaning
but the natural world is full of
encounter and that encounter generates
an aliveness and a relational meaning
making quality that just makes life feel
very very rich and we lived like that
for thousands of years before we lived
on discord
were there any other aspects of the
experience that were particularly
surprising to you in any way or any
other rules that you set for yourself
that proved either
fruitless or fruitful
i mean the one encounter that comes to
mind and there were many is you know
lots of solo hours tracking which felt
very special but on one of the nights i
got caught in a storm a thunderstorm
rolled in and the heat built all through
the afternoon
and i could see the storm building out
over the western horizon
and it started to look menacing and then
even more menacing and i was living on a
flat platform up in the tree
and eventually the wind started to howl
and blow and then the mother and the
father of a thunderstorm broke around me
and
you know the lightning bolts were coming
around around me and i don't know if
you've ever been very close to lightning
strikes but the first thing is that you
just hear it go like this
and then the blade comes down
and then the sound goes sonic but if
you're close enough to it it actually
clicks as it hits the ground
boom and it started to come down around
me torrential rain and blades of
lightning lighting up around me and the
sound was just so intense and i mean it
was just monstrous and i was um
i was cast into a deep and overwhelming
fear
and i realized that i can imagine
i realized that like true fear is like
true fear
is kind of a rare experience in modern
life
it's so different to neuroses terror
right like terror is a it's a it's a
very distinct thing it's so distinct to
like all my anxiety
you know all the things i worry about
but like true
raw i don't know if we make it out of
this fear is actually a very rare
encounter in life
and
you know it would not end i just kept
saying to myself like you can't be this
scared for so long surely it's just
gonna pass and then like another hour
and another hour
um
and i just kind of weathered it and i
felt an incredible
yeah i mean i guess it's
talked about a lot but an incredible
fragility
and an incredible humility
and then the next day when i came out of
it i also felt like
oh god that scared me so much but i
would i would do it again you know just
to like on the other side of it to have
been like in a storm like that
was felt felt very very very special i
felt like profoundly like a profound
encounter with the force of nature
do you think
you will ever do an extended period
solo like that again i don't know if you
were totally solo i have no idea if you
were solo solo solo or i was like solo
most of the time but a few people come
out and say hi every once in a while but
do you
maybe you could clarify that but do you
think you would repeat an experiment
like that why or why not not necessarily
in a tree but that that degree of
solitude
i mean without a shadow of a dart it is
one of the most
beautiful things i've ever done and i
don't know if i will do six weeks again
but i will certainly try and get 10 days
solo in nature a year with no other
people and in this one i didn't see
other people i was totally by myself and
you know there's amazing things that
happen when you're by yourself one is
you know getting really into your own
energy
just being in your own energetic field
then being attuned to nature and feeling
your body start to attune to those
rhythms you know watching the stars move
through the sky all night and feeling
yourself naturally wake up with the dawn
and go to sleep when it gets dark and
feeling your whole circadian rhythm
attuned to that
you know funny things happen like on the
one day i banged my head i had a trunk
which had dry goods in it but i banged
my hand on the trunk
i was like ah
god you know damn it
and
and i i flew into a rage
i like i flew into a rage because it was
so painful and then i realized that with
no one else around
i couldn't maintain my state of anger
and it's a really weird thing like
sulking being angry and sulking and
moods and all of that stuff is really
for the benefit of other people
it's really so that other people can get
tuned in to like what a difficult time
you're having but when you buy yourself
they just do not abide because there's
no one around to like stay in the story
for
well speaking of mood part of the reason
i'm asking is because i know you and i
have both experienced in life depressive
episodes
and i suppose there's part of me that
thinks man 40 days is a long time
to be alone with the voices in your head
but did you find
how did you find that experience was
that even a concern going into it for
you
how did you if you did think about it
how did you think about that no i mean
it's certainly a concern
and then there's also this weird
component of time right like you wake up
at four in the morning you meditate you
go tracking for a few hours you come
back to the camp you make some coffee
you run
you do some more reading and journaling
you meditate again and it's 10 15
and you have
39 days to go
but the one thing is that i you know i
was not doing like traditional zen
retreat i allowed myself books
i allowed myself to do daily recordings
of my encounters like kind of journal
entries
and i allowed myself to go tracking
and so actually it was incredibly
generative for me and there's all these
like little problems you have to solve
like you got to keep your camp clean and
then everything gets wet and then you
got to work out how to build yourself a
bit of shelter and then you know like
but every once you become more present
it becomes so full of life like i would
make myself this evening shower i'd go
full some full of big cast iron kettle
with water and then i would warm it on
the fire and then i would pour this
kettle of hot water over myself totally
alone up in the tree it was the best
shower i've ever had and just it was
teaching me presents all the time and
and i actually
the once the anxiety left there was a
lot of introspection and i looked at a
lot of things but i actually didn't feel
myself taken by
by sort of anxious or depressive demons
i've
the process felt very generative and
alive to me yeah that's something that
i've been looking at very very closely
for myself and i i don't think i've yet
perhaps developed the eyes or the
awareness to parse it but the
the difference
the characteristics or the circumstances
that lead to
nourishing solitude versus
depleting
isolation
right because those are very different
for me those concepts represent very
different things right solitude versus
isolation or loneliness
so thank you for answering how does it
feel for you now
like if you went if you went alone for a
week to a cabin now like how does it
land on you now
a week i could do week i can do and i
could find that i think very restorative
i particularly find it restorative if i
am with molly my dog and have that
close connection going through
wilderness with molly
is particularly
nourishing to me i can also do it solo
but i find that she and i are so attuned
at this point
because we spend
almost
all of our waking time together that
she's like my external nervous system
she's almost like a
amplifier for my own nervous system so
i'm picking up what i'm picking up but
i'm also picking up a lot of what she is
picking up just by observing her
behavior
and
that
is
very additive for me
and also deepens my relationship not
only with the surroundings and with
myself on some level but with her
so week
a week i would would take no problem i
think the the six week starts to get out
to a point where i'm like i wonder right
there's just a question mark because i
haven't done six weeks
solo that's a that's a pretty good
stretch of time
yeah
i mean i will say that it was largely
supplemented by the passion for tracking
yeah and so you know your encounter with
like feeling the presence of molly there
and you know being in this thing
together like my feeling is every time
i'm tracking i'm in a new story right
every time i'm out there following i'm
i'm in a deep encounter and it actually
feels
like there's this alive sentience
awareness
one of the things that i would say
is that when i first went out i thought
that part of what i was doing is i
wanted to improve my attunement to
nature like i wanted to know nature
but one of the most profound experiences
out of it was
that i started to feel known by nature
yeah yeah for sure and i know that this
maybe veers us off a little bit into the
esoteric but there was this feeling that
there's this sentient alive
consciousness and somehow
it was feeling me as i was feeling it
in a really deep way yeah and that felt
actually
that felt incredibly supportive and like
i was
touching something really beautiful and
special yeah i think there's a lot to
that but lest we get too far down the uh
rabbit hole into crazy town
which maybe maybe we'll do on a round
two definitely do around a campfire in
person
but i i think there's actually a lot
there related to what you just said
i do want to
discuss your healing process and this is
going to seem like a very strange way to
approach it
before we get to that
i feel like maybe
like ginger and the sushi meal will just
give people a story as a is a quick
refresher
slash palette cleanser and then we'll
then we'll dig into some heavy stuff so
are you willing to tell the story about
the
bees oh absolutely
well i guess i guess we bonded over the
story
you know people people ask me a lot like
what's the most dangerous encounter
you've had in nature
and
you know by this stage of the podcast
you know a crocodile tried to ingest me
and that wasn't the worst
um
but i became fascinated by bees
for a few reasons the one is that one
day i was walking
in the wild part of zimbabwe
and i came across this ancient baobab
tree this two-story high baobab tree and
it had been hollowed out by an elephant
had knocked the branch and it was in
fact empty and a swarm of bees had made
their hive in the top of it and the
sound of the bees humming was coming
down the base of that tree and it was
like standing next to this giant
didgeridoo
and just the sort of i could hear the
intensity of the bees through this
process and i felt their vibration
coming out of this tree and it was it
kind of sparked my interest
there's also an amazing thing
in southern africa there's a bird called
the honey guide
and literally if you go out in parts of
wilderness in africa and you start
banging on trees
a bird will come to you and it will
start to call incredibly animatedly very
much like disney's i think he wants us
to follow him and then it will fly in
front of you and show you where the
beehive is so that like for thousands of
years before as a hunter-gatherer you
can rob the beehive and then you put
some honey down next to you and the bird
comes and lands next to you and eats the
honey it's this incredible ancient
just you know it's an encounter like
that like it just takes you back
thousands of years in an instant wow so
wait just just for clarity so this is
this is like
thousands tens of thousands who knows
hundreds of thousands of years of
co-evolution where this bird has a
species memory
of
a symbiotic relationship with humanoids
is that what i'm hearing a type of
morphogenic field memory that's nuts
when it sees a person it knows we go and
get honey together wow isn't that
amazing that's cool and you walk out to
remote places and suddenly the birds in
it's like come on let's do this are we
going to do this and it almost appears
to get disappointed if you're like i'm
not going to go and rob the beehive now
wow so anyway like i was around with
this idea and i was like the bees are
really fascinating and then i started
reading up on them
and it's this incredible creature right
they pollinate millions of flowers
they're one of the biggest contributors
from the insect world to the economy
honey sales they can feel
electromagnetic fields they will
disappear if a storm is brewing
and then as you watch the hive itself
this incredible kind of
algorithmic intelligence whereby a
single bee an individual b responds to
localized stimuli doing what it knows to
do
and when enough bees
responding to individual localized
stimuli
all start to attune an algorithm fires
through the hive and they move as one
and they know where to go and get food
etc so that idea also gripped me the
idea of individuals attuning to what
they know to do can trigger a kind of a
collective transformation
so i got really into this that's all the
good stuff there's a bit of backstory
here before my near-death experience so
wait i should tell you that during the
time that i got fascinated about bees
there was a couple who were coming on
safari and they had been writing to me
from singapore and they were saying
listen we want to come to africa but
we're terrified of ebola
and i had said to them listen ebola is
in you know north and west africa
there's no ebola in south africa yeah
but we're very very afraid of it we're
very concerned that it could travel i
said
you really have to trust me there is no
ebola in south africa you're going to be
absolutely safe
so they had come on safari meantime i
walk up into the back of the village
and i seek out a man by the name of
simon [ __ ]
simon [ __ ] great name himself has a
mellifluous voice very soft lilting
voice and simon [ __ ] is the village
beekeeper
so i say to him
simon i've got really interested in bees
and i know that you have some hives and
i would love to come and experience your
beekeeping he says okay
there's no problem i can take your
beekeeping
i said him great i'm excited about this
he says you meet me tomorrow in the
morning and we will go and meet the bees
great next morning i meet him
and he's got a big sort of black plastic
case
and we drive out to the hives and i'm
inappropriately dressed i'm in like
shorts and t-shirt
and i said him what do we do now he says
okay
the first thing is you must put on your
beekeeping suit
so he gives me his suit and i put it on
and it's a little bit short for me like
literally between my sneaker and my
ankle i have some exposure
so i said to him simon the suit's a bit
short for me because he had sort of this
was his second suit he says
don't worry
you can borrow my socks
so he takes his boots off and he's got
thick black socks and so i sort of feel
them and i think okay this is going to
be good and i put the socks on and i
like seal up the suit
and i say to him cool simon let's get
the smoker going now he says oh no i
don't use the smoker
it makes the bees afraid of a fire
so like a little bell goes off in my
head i'm like but beekeepers all over
the world use the smoker he says it's
not my style
i'm like oh yeah i'm here to learn
and so simon and i start heading towards
the hives and i'm talking african bees
here now some amazing thing happens
as you approach the hive
if you just walk past the hive with no
intention of doing anything
the bees somehow know it but the minute
you put your intention and attention on
them
i don't know how
you know it's maybe too woo but i'm
telling you they feel it and as you
start walking towards the hive they
start changing gears like they're at the
austin f1 track
you hear the sound changing so we get up
next to the hive and simon gets out his
crowbar and he cranks the lid off and 70
000 of the most enraged
african bees rise up in a black cloud
around me
and they're shimmering around me and you
can feel the intensity and you can feel
their attitude of oh you think you can
[ __ ] with us
and they're all around you and they
start to land on you and it i you know
someone who's grown up around animals i
feel the energy of a single angry
aggressive animal
and they're all over me and i say simon
this is quite intense he says don't
worry everything's okay
and they start landing on the visor and
like blocking the visor out and it's
super intense and right at that moment
in the midst of this like
raw buzzing intensity
1b
found
my weak sock area
and it stung me through the sock
and the minute as that sting went
through the sock
a huge pheromonal cascade was released
to the other bees and the shimmering
swarming dark mass around my head
[Applause]
it stopped for a second
and then as one the bees went to my
ankles
and they begin to sting me intensely
through the socks the socks do not work
so i think simon simon they're stinging
me
simon simon they sing me what does i do
what does it do he says okay
back away
and they start following me and then i'm
being sung hundreds of times and then at
one stage i look up and there's a bee
that has
that's inside the suit so eventually i
get into the clearing and now i have a
swarm of bees around me they are still
penetrating the sock belly says simon
what must i do what does he do he says
uh hold on i will help you
and he runs over and he cuts a large
branch of a tree and then he runs back
and he starts beating me with the branch
so now i'm standing in the clearing
getting pounded with the branch and
they're still stinging me they're still
all around me
simon it's not working it's not working
he says okay i will get the smoker going
and i just the thought ran to my head
like a little late for that
he grabbed the smoke he starts putting
elephant dung in it and then he gets it
going and he comes over to me and he
starts blasting me with the smoker and
the first blast went right through the
visor of the beekeeping and kind of into
my mouth and so i got a big inhale of
elephant dung and then my mind and my
chest immediately tightened up i started
thinking [ __ ] my whole body is going
into anaphylaxis is it elephant dung or
is it anaphylaxis and they're still
stinging me and it's bad i said i'm
simon they're still seeing me they're
still seeing me says uh okay
run for your life
and this is when two men in beekeeping
suits break into a full run through the
wilderness and we just start running
aimlessly at first and then he says they
will chase you forever make for the land
rover
so we run to the land rover and we jump
into it and he just says drive drive
drive they are enraged
i start driving off into the wilderness
nuts we come around the first corner
and on the other safari truck driving
towards us is the couple from singapore
who've been afraid of ebola and they see
what they see is the ebola cleanup crew
in full white suits
driving towards them at full street
going you're gonna die you're gonna die
drive drive drive
and that was my first encounter with the
bee so eventually i make it back to the
house
and i remember i got into my my bedroom
and i sat on the bed and i was just
trying to feel my own body and i was
like
am i dying
am i am i dying am i okay like is it
kicking in
and i got into the shower and i took all
the stings out of my ankles and i made
it
back onto my bed and that was me for the
next five days i did not move
my my feet looked like someone had taken
um surgical gloves and just blown them
up
[Applause]
and simon would come around and he would
say uh
uh hey boyd how are you doing today said
not good he said i bought some ice for
your feet next time we will get you
boots
but you know i i sat with it and what
what i took out of it was number one
if you wanna
what the bees taught me is if you want
to know about the bees respect the bees
and
the next thing that i got was i became
intrigued by the power of
this collective ability to fire the con
like the collective consciousness
algorithm like what would it mean if we
all started really attending to states
of peace and healing and well-being and
if enough of us did that
could we like the bees you know create
some kind of algorithmic transformation
for everyone
so i got a lot out of it yeah or
stinging the [ __ ] out of some invaders
ankles
intensity they taught me so much about
intensity i think that's what i learned
from independence day if we have aliens
invade that's a great way for us to
activate our high of mind to sting the
[ __ ] out of someone's ankles get the
bees on them oh all right well the segue
back to what i mentioned earlier is
going to be a little awkward so let me
let me find an in-between course to get
us there
that'll maybe lead us back
in some odd way could you speak to the
moment when a
lion
notices you and then what happens
at that point
how does an encounter like that unfold
well again i want to come back to that
idea of the minute a lion becomes aware
of you and you become aware of it you
are in a language dialogue and it is a
language of energy and presence
now there's usually one of two things
that will happen
either the lion will get up and this is
99 of the encounters the lions
natural instinct is to get away from you
remember people hunted lions for
hundreds of years on the plains and
actually one of the primary ways that
hunter-gatherers got food
and a lot of people don't know this is
they tracked lions and then they would
rob them of their kills and so lions
have a long history of being you know
chased by humans so normally it'll go
away from you however that doesn't
always happen
particularly if if a lioness has cubs or
if they or if they have meat they can be
aggressive
now normally what will happen is the
first thing that you will notice
is the animal's body will tighten
they'll drop their head and the tail
starts to flick intensely and they start
to warning growl at you
and it sounds like the growl is so
intense it sounds like someone started a
dirt bike in the bush up ahead of you
and then
if it's a lioness and she's got cubs
she'll stand up and still with her head
low and her ears back and the tail
lashing she slowly starts to walk
towards you
and she fixes you with a gaze
of utter intensity and the minute she
has you in that gaze
your only option
is you have to stand your ground and you
have to communicate an intense presence
back to her
so
when that happens to me if i feel myself
starting to come into an encounter where
we're going to have a more aggressive
energetic conversation with each other
and may i just interject for one second
to say when you don't have clients
true or false you guys will often go out
with just walking sticks yeah no no
rifles without clients okay please
continue what we most believe in is
being in this dialogue
and so if that happens the first thing
that you do is you breathe out a long
out breath
because everything in your system is
starting to jack up because the feeling
of it is like i'm i mean you can feel
your whole system flush with
with uh adrenaline so you breathe out
you anchor yourself
and
then you understand that that line is
trying to communicate with you she walks
towards you intensely intensely and then
she'll growl
and with that she charges and then she
runs at you at full speed and it is in
it's so fast
uh snarling you know full guns revealed
teeth revealed and she comes in
and then you stand your ground and you
look her directly in the eyes
and
mostly what will happen is she'll stop
some distance from you as she stops you
hold her in your energy and you almost
aggressive back to her
and you're showing that like i'm
dangerous too
and then the minute you see her energy
drop a little bit because all that she's
doing is she's trying to anchor you so
that the cubs can run away the minute
you see her energy drop a little bit you
just start dropping away and you give
her still facing her you step back you
give her space
and very quickly you start communicating
to her that we we know we've come too
close but we're going to give you space
now but you can only do that once she
has stopped coming at you and you'll if
you watch her very intensely and rhaenys
is really the master of this as you
watch her closely a slight drop in
energy and he'll move backwards a little
bit and then you you know get out of the
situation and you just find yourself
giggling stupidly
and doing all the weird things that
happen after high tense situations
so you said most of the time they stop
some distance from you so
what
what's the alternate scenario
if you're in the alternate scenario
you've got something very very wrong
yeah
and the reason that you get into the
alternate scenario
is that you get it wrong in the moment
you see as that charge starts happening
you're in the dialogue and your and your
presence is absolutely critical in your
ability to project an energetic presence
and meet her and then for to quickly
help her understand that you're not
afraid of her you're dangerous but
you're also going to give way
and and when people get killed it's
because they get that wrong they fall
over their nerve breaks and they want to
run or they get scared and they start
running immediately that's when
dangerous things happen
you know i don't know if you've ever
come across this book but it's it's one
of my favorite non-fiction books for the
last 10 years
which is saying a lot for me because i
do read
a lot of books and they
already have cleared hurdles right i'm
not just reading whatever i like
randomly pick off of amazon i'm getting
books that are usually recommended by
two or three people first
in in a book called of wolves and men by
barry lopez
who's won a lot of awards he's best
known for a book called arctic dreams
but of wolves and men he talks about
the
conversation between predator and prey
as the conversation of death
and he went out with field biologists
and also with
inuit and
native americans in north america at
various points
and observed
different hunts and also heard stories
from both groups
about
this conversation of death so people
listening might think well that doesn't
make any sense a lion is a predator they
can easily overtake you why wouldn't
they attack you but
time and time again the conversation of
death wouldn't always end in death
sometimes a perfectly capable
say pack of wolves would pursue a
caribou or an elk or something and then
at one point the elk or the caribou
doing about face stand off with the
wolves and then they would just part
ways they'd just walk in opposite
directions and it seems to defy
explanation but it does happen and
i found that entire segment of the book
it comes up a number of times but
talking about the nuances in this
conversation of death and how these
animals interface there seems to be some
communication and
sometimes it ends in death and other
times it just ends in both parties
deciding like okay another day and then
they just
go in different directions it's it's
something i don't have any real
understanding of but i find
endlessly fascinating so it's something
that you've had more
first-hand experience with i suppose i
mean there's just there's a there's a
knowledge out there that is
and if you actually spend talk to any
people biologists feel the more time you
spend in nature
the more you'll realize
how little we know there is subtlety and
nuance and there is things happening out
there that is
way beyond our understanding
yeah there's another example i think
it's in of wolves and men but talking
about how
they're recorded instances of
wolf packs that are being tracked i
presumably with radio callers but maybe
with
flyovers or something like that prior to
the satellite colors because this book
was written in the 70s
that at some point
for no discernible
cause right no
no stimuli that can be identified will
will just pick up and all head off in a
very precise direction in a more or less
straight line and then four days later
they intersect perfectly with a caribou
herd that happens to be migrating but
started at roughly the same time moving
in a different direction
and the two vectors intersect it's like
okay
i mean
that seems interesting i don't know how
to explain that exactly but these types
of phenomena that get observed over and
over again and all and also not to take
us too far afield but these
these
so-called and in some cases they're
certainly mythologies but mythologies
about for instance
in the case of some north american
indians the collaboration between coyote
and badger
so the the joining forces of coyote and
badger which for a long time was thought
to be this quaint fairy tale and then
during quarantine
this is now about a year year and a half
ago there was
some type of trail cam footage
that was released that showed like a
coyote playing with a badger like a
dogwood like wagging its tail and
jumping around and then them leading
leading off through a tunnel on
basically a hunting party right so
there's just
so much we don't know it doesn't
surprise me no i mean even just some of
the stuff around orientation you know
you watch a
you watch a female leopard
walk into walk
five or six
kilometers leave her cub walk five or
six kilometers then hunt in thick
terrain walking circles you know
you know moving in an irregular way
catch an impala hoisted in a tree
and walk a direct line back to where her
cub was
which by anyone's standards would just
be an incredible piece of navigation but
and
you know she doesn't have a verbal mind
or a rational mind but somehow through
all of that circuitous movement she
knows where she left the cub in a more
instinctual way almost yeah and then
you know you find this in in native
people too the capacity for homing
the ability and i've seen it with
trackers who've come down
sam trackers who've come down from the
kalahari they've come into the kruger
national park a terrain they've never
been in
we've taken them into the mapani mapani
is like an eye high scrub and we've
walked for a few hours in the mapani we
have a gps because we know how easy it
is to get lost in there and then
afterwards we've said to them okay take
us back to the vehicle we've got the gps
and they walk on a b line directly back
to where we left the vehicle
it's just like what is that
that's fascinating it makes me wonder
and i think this this might actually be
demonstrated you know if we have some
magnetic homing capability
or navigational ability similar to
hammerhead sharks right so there's
footage people can find of marine
biologists studying hammerhead sharks
with a baby hammerhead sharks in a
aquarium basically and they have
top-down
footage of how the movement changes if
they rearrange
magnets underneath the encasement
so many unanswered questions
which which is very exciting to me
obviously
because if everything were discovered
that wouldn't be
that would be quite depressing in and of
itself
so let's let's come back to these
traumatic events in your safe
early twenties eighteen to twenties and
then what followed after that
how how did your
healing path
this might seem like a strange way to
lead in but
differ from those of your mom and sister
right because they're also
presumably
traumatized by the the home invasion if
you're open to speaking to it you could
you could just speak to your own
personal experience but i'm curious
how different people have
approached
finding some degree of closure
resolution healing after an experience
like that
well i think for one thing there was a
masculine feminine component to that
they
they did a lot more post-traumatic
counseling at the time
and i wasn't open to that i thought you
know the way that i'd grown up i thought
like i'm just gonna get on with it and
and move forward which is uh
you know a naive approach to say the
least
and then
there was also a challenge that i had
where
i think
in the masculine it was harder just to
process
just process feelings what i needed was
a path that i felt was taking me
somewhere and so where that where that
really took root for me is
when i started to understand that if i
was willing to look at how i'd become
frozen if i was willing to look at how i
was anxious and depressed as a result of
that
and how that kind of shut me out from
living and if i was able to start living
towards that
it actually gave me
a kind of map out of trauma you know
someone trauma healed becomes a kind of
medicine and so it was only really when
i started to understand that
that there was value to this just beyond
myself and in fact if i if i became
someone who learned how to be in a
transformational process and learned how
to heal
it was actually taking me towards what i
was meant to do in some very important
way and somehow
that structure of meaning had to take
root in me before i was really able to
dive into healing spaces and be open to
to that type of work
and it was it was different for my
mother and sister they were able to in a
more feminine way allow that process
earlier for me there had to be a
structure of meaning that allowed me to
engage in healing
and be soft enough and to learn to
soften and to learn to open and to learn
to let myself actually feel what was
there and the fear that was there and
the uncertainty that was there
and also a feeling that i didn't know
what i really wanted to do i had a
family legacy in conservation you know i
had a safari business that i could come
into but i i did not i didn't want to
just run safaris i knew there was
something else for me
and i had to go on that journey to find
out what that was
when you say structured meaning do you
elaborate on
what that means might seem a little
recursive as a question but
how did you find that structure meaning
that you needed to move forth
with
contending with what had happened
well a few ways one is so what i mean by
that is okay so if you've had a
traumatic encounter
in the way that i understand it
it's like a part of you becomes frozen
and almost inevitably where there's been
trauma there is a reduction of options
which means
i have less choices
and and that gets laid down so life
starts to become limited and there's
less access to different choices a
healthy person could say you know here's
here's a way of handling this he has a
different way of handling it a
traumatized person has one way of
handling it retreat and isolate for
example and then i was lucky to have
martha and she started to expose me
to how a healing process works and then
very soon after that i found ceremony
work
and what i realized is that part for me
and for many people just for contact for
people listening could you define
ceremony work
there are obviously many different ways
of being in ceremony you might say that
aaa is a ceremonial space
all the way to
sweat lodge spaces all the way to
gatherings using
plant medicines there's just an array
i found myself in spaces using plant
medicines that were very well
guided and
so the first part of the journey for me
was actually acknowledging that i was
frozen so there was building awareness
around how i'd become frozen
and then in ceremony watching
you know drinking the medicine being
with people who were in
in a healing energetic and then watching
how that affected my life
getting to know
how i was when i was frozen
then making peace with that
as opposed to thinking there was
something wrong with me that was a big
movement being like this has happened
this is where i'm at and that's okay
then starting to give myself different
options
so instead of just being isolated and
frozen
starting to actually be able to share
the things that i was ashamed of in some
ways i was ashamed that i hadn't been
able to protect my parents
my sister and my my mother and i was
ashamed that i had left
you know bad guys in the house i was the
man of the house all these things i was
able to start to be able to share these
things that i was ashamed of and
i was able to talk to how disempowered i
had felt in and
unable
to do what i needed to do and so i
started to generate awareness out of
that and then i started to realize that
in sharing that it actually opened me to
deeper connection as opposed to
what i thought it would do which would
would shut me out and shun me
and then i started to
because i was well guided
i started to generate a narrative
that was supported and what i mean by
that is like the guide started to help
me
generate a narrative of the things that
have happened to me can actually be
fodder for growth and learning
and that became really important and
then it actually became you know i have
some gifts
in this and if i can find those gifts
and share them that's probably the most
healing thing i can do
and so i was in that process for a long
time uh
and it and i and at a certain point in
it i started to realize in fact this is
taking me to my work and that's when i
started to see the tracker differently
and i started to really understand how a
transformational process
is an intricate unfolding and as a guide
you can support it as a storyteller you
can support it with presence you can
support it by just listening you can
support it by creating spaces that
people can actually be open in and you
can actually start to know the way
certain trauma patterns work and help
people develop awareness and different
outcomes for themselves
and so my healing was actually about
finding the purpose to help healing come
into the world
if that makes sense
it does make sense and i i wish at some
point i'll show you all the the
highlights and underlying sections in
your book
and i think i might have shown you
a photograph of the index that i created
just for the highlights at the front of
the book but one of the lines this is on
page 122 of the lion tracker's guide to
life is in these times an authentic life
infused with meaning as a kind of
activism right and then you go on to
explain
why that's the case
and
you know i think about this a lot
and you actually had another quote
way earlier
uh let's see if i can find it from
saint francis of assisi oh man
i wish i could find this because it ties
into it right
wherever you go spread the gospel when
absolutely necessary use words
exactly so don't we all wish more people
would follow that advice
and perhaps advice we should give
ourselves as often or perhaps more often
than we give it to anybody else
and
i think this is
really
critical to highlight in the sense that
in this
day and age in these times
uh yelling and screaming on the internet
and shaming
other people or tearing other people
down can be mistaken for
something constructive
or activism but
in
in reality a very powerful form of
activism is being the example that you
want to see more of in the world right
and holding yourself countable in that
way which is not easy it's really hard
oftentimes to do that and i know
both of us have had tremendous struggles
of different types although i think they
share a lot of common
dna
and
you know a lot of this
seems to
come down to stress testing beliefs if
that makes sense right so if you are if
a component of yourself
kind of along the lines of
ifs or internal family systems if if
people are interested in that they can
they can certainly look that up i did an
interview with
dick schwartz richard schwartz the
founder
but if a component of your personality
or psyche is is
kind of frozen in time and
compartmentalized and you and
when you are put in circumstances that
activate that part of yourself
you your you get tunnel vision with
options and maybe you have one option or
maybe you have two options
you can often reduce that down to a
belief right a statement of some type
and
i'm bringing this up because i would
love to hear how
byron katie's workshops
have been
helpful or not helpful for you because i
know this is something we've spoken
about
and
if they have been helpful what specific
worksheets have been helpful for you
oh my goodness um
can i talk
for a moment to the activism thing and
then come back to byron katie you are
allowed sir stage is yours
so one thing on the activism thing and
i would say it like this and and tim you
know you've been on a healing journey
what i notice
is that a person who heals
has a natural inclination to
want to be of service
and especially if you've had people
who've supported you along the way and
that's not to say that i think i know
how you should heal but there's just
this desire as someone who heals to
support the healing impulse and be there
and you know that there were moments in
your own journey that were very powerful
for you and you want
it's almost just like innate when you
get in touch with that to want to do
that for other people and support that
the way that i think about this is
if you can give yourself a
transformational process and you go on a
journey to discover
you know i would call it the track of
your life the place where you feel whole
where you feel like you're expressing
your essence into the world
the place where you feel
just at peace and in tune with yourself
and it takes time to get to that and
it seems to me that at a certain point
in every lifetime we get asked like
what's it about and it seems to me it's
about that coming to that place in
yourself but there are some
characteristics of people who i see who
deeply find that place
for one they become inclined towards
simplicity
they don't want a lot of things
a feeling of enough comes into them and
both like i am enough and i have enough
and they stop wanting to consume more
things to feel okay
there's a natural desire towards service
there seems to be at this like
inclination that takes them to be pulled
into nature
there's a desire to be creative
and
and support other people and that's what
i mean is that inside of every healing
journey
and when someone goes on that journey
and finds a deeper place of peace and
it's of course it's a continuous journey
but it seems to me that those things
take root and that seems to be very
important for the restoration movement
in a very individual way we do our own
work to heal and come to wholeness but a
whole lot of people coming into that
state of i have enough i i am enough
you know it just changes the desire to
consume endlessly and i think that's
going to be very good for nature and so
i see this like the restoration movement
as both restoring our relationship to
wild places and restoring wild places
but also restoring ourselves coming to
wholeness and healing so that we come
out of the illusion that more stuff is
going to make us feel okay and realize
it's already there in us we need to
discover that gift and share it
so that's a little talk on you know how
people who discover that just become
embodied activists
and then um byron katie's work i cannot
say enough about it i know you've had a
lot of people on the show who have
brought her up
but
there is nothing more profound than
being able to identify thoughts that are
causing you stress and then have a
system to question them
and on a certain point on a journey they
become absolutely critical because if
you are getting touch with this place
inside yourself and it's curious and it
knows sort of what it wants to do and
you feel drawn to a different way of
living inevitably a number of ideas will
come in as to why that's not possible
and so i've done
you know hundreds of worksheets now
and you name it
i've done
absolutely
ridiculous ones and she says like you
know i've done
my mother shouldn't have
you know taken my cake away like
literally like that sort of level of
stuff all the way down to
i'm not safe
or
i'm not going to live the life that i
want to live and you when you sit in it
as meditation
and you
you get to know yourself and that's
where the process changed for me when i
would come up with a thought like
you know i'm never going to achieve what
i want to achieve
when i actually sat like she says to do
in meditation and ask the question
who am i when i believe that thought and
i started to watch
i feel frustrated i feel
let down i don't have confidence in
myself
i feel like i'm never doing enough
i feel like i need to do more i say yes
to things that i don't really want to do
i'm afraid of missing something and and
when i sat in that and got to know
myself there
and then who would i be without the
thought
i would be relaxed i would be open
i would be
really feeling for what's a yes and a no
for me
i would be listening
i would be grateful for where i already
am
i would be thankful for what i have
and so for me
i did the work for a long time before
realizing it was meditation in which i
was getting to know myself as someone
who believed a thought and someone who
didn't believe the thought and only when
i really understood it to be meditation
and i could sit and watch myself like
that did i feel a compassion of getting
to know myself when i believe a thought
and when i don't believe a thought and
how powerful that is and that's when it
the work really took for me
and people can find out more about this
at thework.com it's not a panacea of
course
and uh
kda issues by katie right or people call
her katie and this instead of byron is a
very
unusual woman a unique woman so
well i mean like i'll give you a katie
story like she the first time i ever met
her i was sitting at a conference that
she was talking at and i happened to be
sitting in the second row
she sat down next to me she looked at me
she put her hand out
i took her hand and we held hands for an
hour while other people talked and then
she turned and looked at me and she said
i liked holding your hand and then she
left for the stage
[Music]
that was like my first and that's katie
like totally connected totally wild and
you don't know what's going to happen
right so
it
i suppose i'm saying this all as a
caveat that
if you watch videos which i think are
worth watching but you may think who is
this alien
get me out of here but i would also
suggest that it's worth investigating
the work the worksheets i have found
tremendously valuable for myself
if a
belief is a thought we take to be true
having an actual worksheet and structure
for
stress testing that belief right in the
way that you just described and then
also doing turnarounds where
if
for instance just this one example if
your statement is i am not safe having a
statement i am safe and then being
forced to come up with
examples or evidence that you list out
that you are safe and it is it is
incredibly
practical and powerful for
sort of diffusing the
emotional
boiling point like the sort of entropy
and redline emotional state that then
puts you into this thought loop where
you you create the selective attention
where you only see evidence for whatever
this belief is that you hold 100
yeah i highly recommend people
check that out you know i want to ask
you about something that i don't know
about which is true for a lot of this
and a lot of the follow-up questions
the sweat lodge in arizona
does this does this cue anything for you
that was my first medicine encounter all
right please say more it happened really
early on i was i had just been through
those two traumatic encounters
and
i was severely kind of
unsure of what i was meant to be doing
and i was staying in
in arizona with martha and
another woman who was apprenticing with
her who was a horse whisperer by the
name of cowell simpson
she had ties to the navajo community
and she invited me to attend to a sweat
and so i was you know i'd never been
exposed to that before so i was really
interested
and so we went to the sweat and we ended
up on a kind of a church ground
on the outskirts of phoenix and it was
one of those classic
encounters of like um
what do they say like first the
enlightenment and then the and then the
laundry type thing it was like i knew
that it was a very big kind of
experience i was about to have it was a
spiritual encounter there was a medicine
man coming in but we were also in kind
of this like abandoned churchyard and it
was and then like
the medicine man arrived and he had just
like left his job on a friday afternoon
in construction
and i so i was like trying to catch up a
little bit with it but the minute the
ceremony started i started to feel the
energy
and
we went into the sweat lodge
we drank the medicine so in this case
just to describe for people like how
tall is a sweat lodge how many people
it's it's presumably completely dark i
mean once the door closes it's like
short
like classic hogan with blankets over it
you got a crouch to get into it
like fire area in the middle where the
stones come
huge fire outside where the guys are
really heating up the rocks
and then over the course of about five
hours
the stones just keep coming in and the
heat just keeps building and people
start to sing and we were joined by
various other people who had come to the
ceremony
and it was all native people and myself
and cowell
and everyone started singing
and the energy started to build and then
more heat and then more singing and then
drum and then more heat and it just
keeps on building and then people
started to
let go of things that they were holding
and so people started to scream and
people started to cry and the music
builds and the singing builds and you
can almost feel like the energy is like
conjuring
more and more energy it's like building
on itself and it's getting super intense
and
and eventually
the heat was getting too hot for me and
i could feel like i'd been told like
don't leave the sweat lodge but i'm like
this is too much
and then the mids and then the singing
and suddenly i found myself
uh in this kind of slideshow and my eyes
were closed tim but i saw
you know i saw the gun in my face i saw
my sister tied up i saw the crocodile
just break the surface of the water i
saw you know all of these images and the
gun to being taken outside kneeling down
being told you're going to be killed the
the words and we're going to kill you
we're going to kill you it all just ran
through my mind and and with
vivid vivid imagery and then eventually
it got to the point where it was almost
too much and i just started throwing up
and as i started throwing up the entire
imagery changed
and
suddenly i was in the vision i was back
home in south africa
and i was sitting in a clearing in the
late afternoon light
and walking across the clearing towards
me came the mother leopard
and she walked through the the short
grass and she walked directly up to me
in the vision and she just bumped me as
she walked past me
and in the instant that she bumped me
something in me understood that
my own healing
and the healing
of nature and the healing of the land
was somehow connected
and that's why all i've ever done now is
try and tell stories from this place of
nature has so much to teach us if we can
attune to it and then i passed out oh
you passed out in the sweat i passed out
in the sweat
and there was like this vibrational
quality to it i know you have some
experience with these medicines but it
was almost like i could feel the humming
of the earth and then eventually
i came to and i was outside the sweat
and i was lying in a pile of leaves that
someone had raked up earlier in the day
but i was like in the leaves and i could
feel the earth and i could feel like the
leaves all around me
and
i looked up and this navajo medicine man
was pouring water up and down my spine
and
i was disoriented and i said to him i
think i'm dying i think i'm dying and he
kneel kneeled down and he put his mouth
right to my ear and he said
no brother you're just being born
it was i was like
and it was weird and i said but i don't
understand what's happening and he said
you'll only understand in the next few
weeks
and he was right like it took long time
to integrate that
but that was really the beginning of my
understanding that the restoration of
our relationship with the natural world
can begin inside each one of us as each
one of us heals we create an opportunity
to to create a different relationship
with the natural world
and somehow that imagery spoke to
the freezing the trauma
that we all go through and the
opportunity to awaken back to our nature
what did you find
unfolded stuck didn't stick for you over
the subsequent weeks
you know that voice stayed with me that
whisper you're just being born because i
felt newborn and i know that
you know you probably know this place
and many of your listeners who've had
psychedelic experiences will know there
can be the sense of being
new and
and like almost baby like sensitized
again
um you're feeling again you feel
again you can feel people's emotions and
for me it was just that like i was
feeling again after that experience and
all of the armor that i had put on had
come off
and i was able to slowly start
i was i felt other people's pain i felt
other people's sadness i felt my own
and i did feel like brand new inside of
that and it wasn't all together
comfortable
but at least i felt back in some ways
in fact it felt incredibly uncomfortable
but i knew that it was better than where
i was
you know
i was
recently
spending time with a
expedition guide who's spent all sorts
of time in
on everest and denali and k2 really
really fantastic guy and his name is eli
and
we
happened to see the
solar eclipse
together uh this is a few weeks ago his
first first time i'd ever seen a solar
eclipse and i think it was the first
time he'd ever seen a solar eclipse and
i asked him how
he
how it was for him and he said you know
i went up to some of my
some of my friends here at camp and i
said that i'm like
i'm not sure what this is it's it's uh
it's like i'm wetting my pants but it's
in my chest i think they might be
feelings
[Laughter]
it's this warm feeling in my chest i
don't know it's like i'm peeing my pants
in my chest they might just be feelings
it's so funny because i had this buddy
of mine who's a navy seal
and he says to me uh
so
i recently um met this dog named butters
and
i find myself thinking about butters
and he's a friend of mine's dog and i go
out and i think about butters and i'm
always worried about butters and i take
butters treats and i go over there i
always want to check on butters and
what do you make of that
like
i i think that's called love he's like
yeah i always feel bad it's right here
in my church like
i think you're i think you're having the
experience of loving butters and he was
like this is outrageous
yeah sometimes sometimes we have to
build the vocabulary learn the abcs
or just like rebuild them reactivate
them
uh
leopard in the fire
this is this is another cue
and just for people who are wondering
what the hell i'm doing with these cues
sometimes i will ask people or i'll ask
my research team to give me cues
for stories they think
will be fun or
productive or profound or interesting to
explore but i don't want to know them in
advance right because otherwise
conversation is less fun for me so
leopard in the fire what does leopard in
the refire
refer to
leopard in the fire occurred
there's kind of two parts to the story
the first is that
when i was very young i heard a story
around a campfire that like stuck inside
of me
and it was a story about a man by the
name of lawrence thunderpost
and thunderpost you may have come across
some of his work but he was a tremendous
poet and an artist and he had one of
those miraculous lives he was a
philosopher really
but thunder past grew up on a farm in
south africa he was very connected to
the native people he learned to track
when he was young and then he ended up
going to fight in the second world war
and in fact in the second world war he
was eventually taken prisoner he was in
a prisoner of war camp
and the story as i heard it was that he
returned to south africa after the war
and he really wanted to go and see his
family
but he felt
he couldn't face them after the things
that he had seen and that he had done
and so instead of going to see his
family he decided that he would go alone
into the kruger national park very near
where
i grew up
so he packed up his gear and he walked
out into the reserve
and he set up this little camp
and this is of course before the days of
diagnosis like ptsd
and the story goes on the very first
night he was sitting at the base of a
marilla tree next to the small waterhole
and i can imagine after the war the
stillness he must have felt and
somewhere nearby a hyenas started
calling
and then a naija would have called
somewhere you know dear lord deliver us.
and i think of him sitting there in that
stillness after the war and on the other
side of the waterhole a kudu
started to
come towards the waterhole to drink and
he sat incredibly still and the kudu is
like a large antelope ah this beautiful
regal animal and it moves with this
incredible elegance
and the kuru the walk to the edge of the
water hole and then with these huge ears
its ears listened and you can actually
see the ears moving like satellite
dishes as they listen and it scanned the
terrain all around and then very slowly
it put its lips down and it started to
drink
and just as it started to drink a breeze
touched thunder post's back and it blew
his scent over
the waterhole and straight into the
nostrils of the kuru and it put its head
up and it looked directly at him
and for a moment their eyes met
and thunderpost said that in that moment
in the stillness of that gaze
he felt a kind of innocence come back
into him after all he had seen and all
he had done in the war
and instantly in that moment he knew he
was able to go and see his family again
and
like as a young kid i think i was maybe
eight or nine when i was sitting around
the fire and i first heard the story and
i
i didn't even know why but it struck
something in me and
years later after the crocodile
sully and i had been sitting around the
fire and he'd we'd been talking a lot
and i was recovering and that the
experience of being attacked by the
crocodile was
it was profound because really it had
brought me closer to sully and i had
learned so much about how he saw the
world and his world view was starting to
come into me a more relational way of
relating to nature and to other people
but still i felt myself incredibly
anxious and frozen i i literally felt
like i had the shake in my body and i
couldn't get it out like i would look at
my hand and my hand would be shaking i
would wake up at night
i had pretty severe ptsd
and into the teeth of this a fire broke
out on the reserve
and i don't know if you've ever been in
a big bush fire but the first thing you
notice about a bushfire is just i have
not is the intensity of the sound
it sounds like it hisses and crackles up
ahead of you
the smoke drifts across the sun and it
bathes everything in this eerie orange
light and then insects that are escaping
the blaze start flying up and what you
get is an aura of hawks and eagles
hawking insects out the sky you feel the
ground start to shake if you go out to
fight it and you look to your right and
out of the smoke comes a rhino
and it books past you snakes escaping
the fire coming past you
and in this instant tim with ptsd i was
highly activated and we fought that fire
for three days
and then eventually on the eve of the
third day the fire had burned through
and the crews were still fighting it but
i had been become isolated from them i
was about a mile or two away from them
and i was in an area that the fire had
already burned through
and night was starting to fall and i
could see the cruise on the horizon in
the distance and i could still see the
fire was lighting the sky in this big
orange blaze
and in fact the area that i was in the
smoke was still hanging on the ground
all around me
and in the darkness to my right i heard
a sound like someone cutting a two by
four
and immediately i knew that there was a
leopard in the darkness to the right of
me
and so i turned to look and walking out
of the darkness into the faint light
that the fire was throwing came this
male leopard
and he was walking directly towards me
which is extremely one it was strange
that he was in an area where there'd
been a fire and two it was strange that
he was walking directly towards me
and when i saw him
and i looked at him and i and he became
aware that i was aware of him no
aggression came into his body he didn't
drop his head he didn't tighten his
shoulders he just continued to walk
towards me
and i in fact dropped down onto my
haunches
and part of what i wanted to do is he
wasn't being aggressive so i dropped
down
because i wanted to give myself the
space to escalate if he became
aggressive i would stand up and if he
became more aggressive i could put my
arms up i was giving myself room to
create more energy
and he continued to move towards me and
as i watched him
he was walking through the smoke and the
smoke was almost dancing around him and
his eyes were lit by the fire on the
horizon
and
his whole coat that beautiful rosetted
coat was bathed in this beautiful
deep orange light from the fire
and he continued to come towards me
and as he walked towards me i felt this
very ancient primal energy wake up
inside of me
and then he stopped when he was about 10
yards away
and he was so close to me that i could
hear him breathing
and
what it felt like to me
is that in that moment it was as if i
could feel his body in my body
and i could feel my body almost creating
a kind of mimesis to his energy and i
felt myself becoming incredibly alert
but incredibly still
and there was no thought of the future
and there was no thought of the past it
was just an energy circulating between
this incredibly beautiful wild elusive
dangerous cat and i
and then slowly he turned to look at me
and then he walked past the front of me
and in a moment he disappeared into the
darkness
and as he walked away from me
and i felt into my own body instead of
more anxiety and fear
and this shake that i had had i felt
myself in this profound state of of
stillness
and i knew in that moment that that
leopard had helped me understand what
happened to fund a post
and i also knew
that i had gone to a place in myself
that i could never have gone to alone
that leopard had had almost
taken me into a state of stillness
and if i think about that ubuntu
consciousness that relational
consciousness if what sully taught me
was that the ubuntu consciousness is
activated through action
and what the leopard taught me in that
moment and what i think thunder deposit
experienced is that the ubuntu
consciousness the relational
consciousness is also activated when we
in a moment let go
and let someone else take us to a place
we couldn't get to ourselves and or
another sentient being
and i think about that a lot as someone
who tends to be quite controlling like
there comes a point where i want to let
go and and go somewhere where i just
can't get to with my own control my own
sense of how it should be my own sense
that i know how this should unfold and
that leopard just took me there in a
moment
and so all through my life i've had
glimpses
of something and i can't exactly say
what it is but i keep living towards it
it's a beautiful story god just the
imagery that conjures this is really i
see it sort of in slow motion almost as
if it's like you know shot on film from
like a francis ford coppola film uh
wow it's uh
it's really just a striking a striking
story and it makes it makes me think of
a few things also you mentioned
a horse whisperer earlier
and for the last few years and i've been
very interested in
these natural encounters of course but
it's it's
very
challenging to manufacture those
experiences
so i've also spent time
looking at for instance equine therapy
and
how
horses are used in
partnership with patients of different
types
for therapeutic purposes and i think it
fascinates me
as many therapies do that are
predominantly non-verbal
i think that we overweight the verbal
perhaps
yeah
so i spent time i wish i could remember
the name but at a number of equine
therapy centers one in texas
and
oddly but maybe not oddly
i also
learned when i went to a wolf sanctuary
and i volunteered there for a period of
time
in colorado and i should explain it's
mission wolf missionwolf.org i recommend
people check it out
in the middle of nowhere in colorado and
they are
you know effectively a
a place of sanctuary for wolves or wolf
dogs that cannot be released into the
wild right so they're not
captive wolves per se they're wolves or
wolf dogs
often who were raised in captivity under
terrible
atrocious circumstances and then
somehow made their way to mission wolf
there are other examples
and
these wolves are not
uh there are also
kind of second generation or
third generation wolves who are very
much wild right like arctic wolves uh
and i mean they're all effectively gray
wolves but come from different areas and
therefore have different coats
and they're in
really large enclosures like multi-acre
enclosures but there are a few
who are
because of their history prior to
getting to
mission wolf are accustomed or not
terrified of human beings like they can
be near humans because wolves by
instinct don't want to be anywhere close
to humans and
if they bark it's usually a fear
response like a fear bark they're not
like dogs at all in that respect
and if they bark i mean they'll they'll
stay as far away from you as possible on
the opposite side of an enclosure
but
when groups come through say school
groups
or visitors
and they have a limited capacity for
visitors which is why i volunteered but
when they come in and there's an
opportunity in some instances to meet
the ambassador wolves they're led into
an enclosure and then they let a number
of these ambassador wolves in
and
i heard repeatedly stories of these
wolves going directly to
whoever was most
internal in a group whoever was most
closed off in a group whether that be
a child with autism or a veteran with
ptsd
and would go right up to them and look
straight into their eyes and i i heard
this story from repeatedly from multiple
staff members
and
much like
fender post and your experience but in
this case with a wolf sort of staring
directly into
the soul of this animal and more
importantly maybe the animal staring
directly into you
many of those people
reporting that it was the first time
they really truly felt seen and i just
feel like there's so much
beauty and value
in that it's something
so worthy of exploration
and it's fascinating that that it can
occur not just from another human not
just from
a prey animal like a kudu but also from
a predator it's very
very very very or a leopard for that
matter i mean it's so deeply interesting
and begets so many questions
i just wanted to mention that because it
was it's also something
having you know looked into the eyes of
a number of these wolves it's
it's very different like the
the presence
not better or worse but just
fundamentally different
in a wolf
as compared to say that that of a dog
they are very different
very different creatures even though the
wolf
is certainly the progenitor of the of
the dog
and i haven't read yet but i think
national geographic had a cover story at
one point called from wolf to wolf which
is one of the best headlines i've ever
heard in my life
but for more info on mission wolf people
can just go to missionwolf.org
and
i think they do some very very
interesting work
i would love to ask you
because you brought up the name
and i can't let you go without asking
for this story
so lauren's fender post that's the name
you mentioned right yeah all right so he
described the lions roar
he said that it it quote
it is to silence what the shooting star
is to the night sky end quote right
tremendous like it's this i know you're
taking me yeah yeah you know where i'm
going this one of a kind
it's one of a kind experience that
cannot be replicated
so please take us to
a
presentation that you gave oh my god
from the beauty of fond du pos quote to
my ridiculous life as a storyteller
yes please so this was early on when i
first started speaking a lot and and
telling stories to people
and i got this gig at one of these
silicon valley companies and normal
story i got there early
and i arrived to meet the tech guy to
make sure that we were well set up
a normal story the tech guy was late
here to have a cigarette break you know
like that archetypal type of tech guy
who's like running the av like it was
that guy
and ceviche i said him like listen man
like i just really want to run through
my slides like i want to make sure that
we're all good and everything he's like
listen i need to upload the system so
that we can stream to the whole company
i'll get you in a second but we're all
good i'm like dude i need to like get
some rips classic like i want to be well
prepared
anyway people start filing in people
start filing in and before i know it the
auditorium is full and i haven't done
the run through
and i'm in my worst nightmare
now the intro to my
intro to my talk
is is a sort of a poetic speech and then
i say and my story
like many good stories in africa begins
with a lion roaring and then i press my
clicker and on a huge screen behind me
there's an early morning image of a male
lion
and he's roaring into the morning so
actually like a mist is coming out of
his mouth and what's meant to happen is
people are meant to be overwhelmed by
this incredible baritone audio
and it's meant to put them right in the
moment and of course
the lion is doing the action of roaring
which is a bit of a convulsion but
there's no sound so you're in the middle
of the presentation you press click and
no sound just a convulsing silent lion
and and it was at this point and it
dawned on me like slow enough for it to
be truly painful that i realized i was
about to roar at a group of executives
and i grabbed the lapel mic and i held
it close to my mouth and then i synced
up my raw with the lion
and the problem with the damn clip is it
went on for a long time
and then when a lion winds down he goes
and so literally the intro and i was
like why won't this lion stop
oh my god it was painful it just went on
and on anyway i got through the
presentation and still to this day tim
i'm going to be honest with you if i lie
in bed and i think about that a wave of
shame will travel through me and i'll
have to like curl over on my side and
just rock myself
oh god did you get any pats on the back
or any uh stiff drinks handed to you
after that one well the thing that saved
the whole damn thing is that like
eventually when i finished roaring
one person started clapping and everyone
like went for it and so the whole room
ended up clapping and that like kind of
like moved the energy and we were into
the presentation i was like thank god oh
god thank god for lauren or whoever that
was
yeah thanks lauren it was like one of
those moments also where you realized
like you can't half raw at a group of
executives like you've either got to not
do it or go all in
like let's go
thanks for nothing av guy oh yeah such a
great story so i i gotta say so first
for people listening
get a copy of the lion tracker's guide
to life i rarely
make an endorsement like that it's a
small book you can read it in one or two
nights or afternoons
and
as i mentioned it's one of the few books
that i have an entire shelf dedicated to
in my guest bedroom it found me at the
right time you know so maybe it doesn't
find everyone at the right time but for
me
it really found me at the right time and
it's a book i've re-read which is also
something i cannot say
for many books and
you work with
individuals you work with companies
i find your approach to life and sort of
your
multi-sensory multi-modality
perspective
on life to be not just fascinating but
but very practical you've spent a lot of
time
testing developing inheriting learning
tools
and i think that you know as you
mentioned
given the trauma that you've experienced
and the
the
challenges that you've had to overcome
like you you can
some people and i think you have
certainly done this can convert that
pain and that university of suffering
into part of the medicine that you bring
to the world and i think you do that
not just well but very beautifully so
first i just want to thank you for that
so oh thank you tim i really appreciate
you saying that
yeah absolutely and
i just wanted to know if there's if
there's anything i want to leave a
couple of stories i still have a couple
of notes which i don't know the the
context behind but i want to save a
couple in case we do a round two
although i know you have no shortages
i might ask you about uh
was it your uncle and the boat with the
outboard i can't remember who it was but
that'll have to be safe
but some of them only get pulled out
with a bit of you know scotch and a
campfire so all right well well round
two might be with scotch and a campfire
it'll be our next one but is there
anything you would like to
say any
last closing comments for the audience
request recommendation anything at all
anything else
something you'd like to point their
attention to
anything at all that you'd like to
to share before we wind to a close this
time around
well first year just thanks for having
me and you know it's privileged to
support a show that has had such an
impact on so many people and be a part
of it so i'm just really grateful to you
and been fun getting to know you
i would say a few things i would say one
is i would invite people to come on
safaris in africa it's a very unique
encounter with with a landscape that is
still wild
and when people come
and have safaris at a place like
londolozi or or wherever they go it has
a profound impact on allowing us to
protect these areas and on the local
people
and so you know we've always been i've
always been a proponent of the economy
of wildlife we keep these areas wild we
invite people to come and experience
them and that has a huge impact so i
would say if you're thinking about
coming
if you're thinking about a holiday come
on a safari if you're thinking about a
safari come it's
it's a once in a lifetime experience
i would say that if you are interested
in tracking you can support the tracker
academy
trackeracademy.co.c they do amazing work
supporting young people
from difficult backgrounds
teaching them to become trackers they
have a nearly 90 placement rate
into the tourism industry so they do
amazing work
and yeah that those would be those would
be the two things that i would offer to
people
where can people learn more about the
safari side if they wanted to learn more
about that
you can get a hold of us
at londolozzi.com
you can also get a hold of me at
boydvarty.com my team will will point
you in the right direction
and
tracker academy yes is
trackeracademy.co.za
za for my fellow americans out there
sorry
i like the zed it sounds more dignified
it's nice to see you boyd great to see
you too tim i'm glad we did this with a
bit of video as well for people who want
to see it on on youtube they can just
search for tim ferriss on youtube and
it'll pop right up
but i know we are many time zones away
at the moment that won't be true
in the in the not too distant future so
i'm looking forward to spending some
time in person
me too man i'm looking forward to
getting you out here we go tracker rhino
i'm i'm excited to track a rhino and i'm
excited not to have any legs eaten by
crocs and
i'm very much looking forward to finally
getting feet on the ground at
londalowski and getting to meet
some of these characters that i have
only read about and heard about at this
point
both human and animal alike so thanks
for taking the time today man i really
appreciate it yeah thank you tim thanks
for having me enjoyed it even more than
i expected to and i expected to enjoy it
a hell of a lot so to everybody
listening you will find show notes to
everything that we discussed at tim.blog
podcast you can just search boydboyd
it'll pop right up you can find them
online at boydvardy.com we'll link to
londolozzi trackeracademy.co.za
and everything else
in the show notes as well as boyd on
twitter at boyd vardy and all the rest
his books the line tracker's guide to
life and his memoir cathedral of the
wild can both be found everywhere books
are sold and
until
next time experiment often
be safe be kinder than is necessary even
just a little bit and
see if you can get out in nature it will
be good medicine for the soul and thanks
for tuning in
you